mais vous le sac
mais n'oublie pas quoi
bienvenue dans la rédaction du figaro et
sur le figaro live nous sommes en direct
sur notre site internet et sur notre
page youtube pour vivre ensemble et
commenter les résultats de ce second
tour des élections législatives
2022 alors qui arrivera en tête emmanuel
macron conservera-t-il sa majorité et le
parierait le pari sera t-il réussi pour
jean luc mélenchon
réponse dans un peu moins d'une heure on
vous les annoncera les premiers
résultats depuis le grand studio du
figaro où vous trouvez vincent roux
absolument en brune bonsoir à tous merci
de nous rejoindre une fois de plus une
fois encore sur le plateau de figaro
live on est très heureux de vous
retrouver on va prendre vos réactions
vos commentaires en direct il ya déjà un
certain nombre de questions qui sont
posées dans le chat en particulier sur
la page youtube du figaro alors majorité
absolue ou à majorité relative qui aura
la majorité qui va arriver en tête ce
sont également les questions que vous
vous posez ce sont également les
questions que nous nous posons et
rassurez vous dans moins d'une heure
maintenant vous aurez la réponse en
direct dans cette nouvelle soirée
électorale sur figaro live
[Musique]
et voici donc déjà un premier chiffre
c'est celui de l'abstention tous les cas
ce sont les estimations ce soir de
l'abstention
54% ce sont des chiffres qu'on va
commenter avec vous vous allez nous dire
d'ailleurs si vous avez voté vous pouvez
nous le dira si vous voulez pas nous le
dire vous en voudra pas mais dites nous
si vous avez voté ou si vous n'avez pas
voté est ce que vous avez voté blanc ou
est-ce que vous êtes rendus aux urnes et
si vous avez fait une de toutes ces
démarches dites nous pourquoi vous
l'avez entreprises on va partager ça
avec nos invités dans un instant mais
auparavant en direct sur la news drôme
du figaro on retrouve bruno dre avec
raphaël lazreg qui sont au service
politique service politique qui est bien
entendu est en première ligne ce soir
pour vous donner toutes les informations
tous les résultats
oui tout à fait donc vous voyez derrière
moi le service politique du figaro et
son rédacteur en chef adjoint jim
jarrassé bonsoir jim comment vous vous
êtes comment vous êtes préparés organisé
pour cette nouvelle soirée électorale
alors on va dire qu'on commence à avoir
un petit retour sur expérience puisque
c'est déjà la quatrième soirée
électorale de l'année donc finalement on
a pris les mêmes recettes que pour la
présence y aller pour le premier tour
des législatives en organisant en amont
avec les différents services du web et
du print cette soirée électorale
pourquoi avoir la même meilleure
couverture à la fois donc
au niveau de la maquette que vous allez
retrouver demain dans le journal et puis
toute la couverture en direct que vous
allez avoir sur le site déjà tout au fil
de la journée et puis à partir de 20h
pour l'annoncé des résultats on a des
envoyés spéciaux dans différentes
circonscriptions et dans les deux qg à
paris d'ensemble et de la nue passe donc
voilà tout ça ça se prévoit plusieurs
jours à l'avance mais encore une fois on
commence à avoir un peu l'habitude quels
sont les trois points que vous allez
particulièrement scruté ce soir le
premier on a on commence déjà à
l'observer c'est l'abstention qui est
estimé autour de 54% pour ce second tour
des législatives un c'est un peu moins
qu'en 2010 est qu'au second tour des
législatives de 2010 est mais ça reste
absolument massif on a observé une
abstention très forte chez les jeunes
près de 70% au premier tour ça nous
interroge beaucoup ça doit interroger
tous les français d'ailleurs et donc on
va forcément analyser ce résultat ce
soir et puis évidemment ce qu'on va
attendre ce soir c'est de savoir si
ensemble si les maquereaux nist dispose
ou non d'une majorité absolue il faut
rappeler que c'est donc 289 sièges à
décrocher pour avoir les mains libres
entre guillemets à l'assemblée donc là
c'est la grande question qu'on va se
poser ce soir est ce que les maquereaux
nice on aura besoin d'aller chercher des
alliés pour pouvoir faire voter des
textes et puis le dernier point c'est on
va quand même scruté de près des
personnalités des ministres notamment on
sait déjà que l'une d'entre elles
justine bénin a déjà perdu en guadeloupe
et va donc devoir démissionner il y aura
peut-être d'autres cas ce soir on va
scruter a notamment à médine montchanin
en essonne stanislas guérini et clément
bonin à paris donc tout ça on va
regarder on va regarder ça de près et
également des personnalités la
république en marche comme richard
ferrand où christophe castaner et puis
alors vous le disiez tout à l'heure il
ya évidemment le journal de demain à
préparer aussi combien de pages on va
avoir sur les législatives de demain
alors demain on a prévu huit pages
organiser un peu comme les pages du
premier tour c'est à dire qu'on commence
par un tableau très globale de la
situation de cette soirée électorale et
puis ensuite on décline quand park en
commençant par celui du président de la
république avec un grand récit qui est
prévu pour revenir un peu sur les ces
derniers jours d'une campagne un peu
compliqué pour le pour le chef de l'état
et puis ensuite la nuque est qu'ils
essayent qui espère voilà réussir son
pari ce soir et on terminera tout ça par
une carte des résultats on pourra voir
une carte de france on pourra retrouver
tous les résultats toutes les situations
pour avoir un panorama complet demain
dans le journal
merci beaucoup de gym je vous laisse
travailler et puis quand à nous enfin si
vous restez avec nous en tout cas
jusqu'à en deuxième partie d'émission
vous pourrez avoir la chance de
découvrir la une du journal de demain
elle sera présentée par le patron des
rédactions alexis brézet donc rester
avec nous c'est avoue vincent vous vous
restez avec nous parce que vous avez
déjà la chance d'avoir en plateau yves
thréard directeur adjoint de la
rédaction du figaro bonsoir et
présentateurs on le rappelle chaque
mardi du club le figaro politique
prochaine édition mardi soir oui tout à
fait
et voilà à tous et donc gaël sliman
également président et fondateur doxa
qui est avec nous pour commenter ces
résultats commentant ces premiers
chiffres bonsoir également à claudius
bonsoir christian léon qui nous
regardent depuis le pays basque ça chez
christian léon que en deuxième partie de
soirée à partir de 22h30 vous pourrez
découvrir les résultats vous pourrez
demander à notre un autre journaliste
animateur thibault gauthier quels sont
les résultats et bien dans l'est dans
les circonscriptions dont ici
circonscription des pyrénées-atlantiques
vous pourrez demander également pendant
que
carl meeus un stage bonsoir bonsoir
je pensais rouler le dimanche dans paris
et c'est une information ça ne roule pas
dimanche d'élections alors c'est pas
forcément peut-être qu'il ya un lien
avec le chiffre qu'on va regarder qu'on
va commenter tout de suite 54% c'est le
chiffre entre les cales estimations de
l'abstention
comme un premier commentaire il faut
écouter c'est très surprenant 1 s'était
ainsi que tout le monde attendait
c'était aux irak et à un sursaut de
vielles tour avec d'un côté ou de
l'autre d'ailleurs chez les nus pour la
majorité présidentielle
la volonté de justement de soin de
marquer des points pour l'une soit de
sauver la face pour l'autre bon
apparemment ça s'est pas produit 54% on
va voir quels sont les résultats et les
causes de tout cela ce fonds connu on
les a maintes fois et maintes fois
détaillé il ya d'abord le fait que les
initiatives s'inscrivent dans la suite
depuis le quinquennat dans la suite du
la présidentielle et que les français
passent et l'élection présidentielle
collection et cardinal et que en fait
ils se sont déplacés deux fois parfois
qu'une d'ailleurs pour la présidentielle
et que quelques semaines après ils ont
pas envie de de confirmer ou de
d'ajuster leur vote la deuxième cause
qui est la cause à mon avis la plus
importante et la plus grave parce que
celle là elle et elle est difficile à
réparer c'est le rejet qu'inspire la
politique n'est pas la politique
qu'inspire le personnel politique aux
français et donc c'était un vote si vous
voulez c'est un nom vote mais un 1 1
n'ont voté dont le silence est
assourdissant et qui nous dit et bien
que
et
la plupart des françaises sont des
français qui rejettent le système et
quand on est dans une démocratie c'est
quand même un cirque et tente un envol
54% c'est si je ne m'abuse gaël le
chiffre que votre sondages avaient prédi
sondage pour le figaro j'ai dernier oui
jeudi dernier on était précisément à
47% donc un point presse sur ce niveau
là ce que c'est s'initie au delà de
l'extraordinaire qualité des mesures de
doxa ça nous dit surtout que les lignes
n'ont pas bougé plus sérieusement entre
le milieu de la semaine dernière le
moment où le terrain d'enquêté effectuée
est ce que nous observons aujourd'hui ça
veut dire que les lignes n'ont pas bougé
depuis le milieu de la semaine dernière
et qu'elle n'avait déjà quasiment pas
bougé par rapport au premier tour et ça
c'est un peut-être un premier
enseignement c'est de se dire qu'il ya
l'appel d'orly d'emmanuel macron n'a pas
mobilisé et de se dire que
fondamentalement les français n'étaient
pas si surpris que ça du résultat du lac
mélenchon non plus non plus alors sauf
que jean luc mélenchon il avait déjà
mobilisé ses troupes ce camp ce que nous
disait quand même comme enseignement
notre sondage pour le figaro du milieu
de semaine réalisée en milieu de semaine
c'est que cette abstention comme
toujours elle est très très typé sur le
plan sociologique mais que les électeurs
du ps alors qu'ils ont un profil plus
populaire et plus jeunes que la moyenne
des autres électorat les électeurs du ps
en particulier reste est étonnamment
mobilisés par rapport à ce qu'on observe
d'habitude c'est que jean luc mélenchon
souffre pas mal de l'abstention quand
elle a lieu la cette résistance qu'ils
avaient elles se confirmera peut-être ce
soir ce sera un des enjeux de ce scrutin
carl
54% l'estimation pour l'instant dans
l'abstention c'est quand même moins je
ne m'abuse que le deuxième tour des
législatives de 2010 est où on s'était
montés à plus de 57% oui alors c'est
moins donc ça veut dire qu'il ya une
petite mobilisation assure qu'une
mobilisation dans un contexte qui n'est
pas évident pas de surplus de
mobilisation par rapport au premier tour
prenez cette comparaison d'il ya cinq
ans
je suivais celle-ci évidemment nous en
fait
moi ce qui me ce que je trouve
intéressant au delà de ce chiffre global
ses devoirs dans dans le détail s'il ya
eu des sueurs froides mobilisation dans
des circonscriptions à enjeu parce qu'au
fond c'est là est ce que quand il y
avait deux candidats qui étaient serrés
dans le score était serré au premier
tour est-ce que les deux camps ont
mobilisé où l'un plus que l'autre pour
le dire autrement est ce que la gauche a
réussi à mobiliser en faisant croire
qu'elles pouvaient soit gouverné soit en
tout cas être l'opposition la plus
importante ni qui par la suite pourrait
bloquer éventuellement certain nombre de
réformes ou est ce qu ensemble a réussi
à mobiliser notamment un électorat drop
sur le thème donné la majorité à mes
yeux marron pour pouvoir gouverner et ça
on va voir dans les circonscriptions où
il y avait vraiment des au jeu on sait
par exemple si on prend le patient n'a
le droit de prendre des carmes et sans
s'en donner 200 donné voilà qu'on n'a
pas du tout cas sympa mais on sait que
parents de christophe castaner c'était
serré donc est ce qu'il a réussi à
mobiliser chez lui dans les alpes de
haute provence on sait que dans le 16ème
à paris et dans ce énième sud ou 16e
nord il y avait une bataille entre des
candidats lrm et des candidats aient
l'air quelque en aura le plus mobilisé
pour pouvoir gagner sonne alain
vigneault chanal en essonne ya un match
qui est qui était au premier tour et qui
là encore on se parle très indécis c'est
un enjeu juste une chose quand même sur
sur ces sur l'indicateur d'abstention
que nous avions au milieu de semaine air
pour illustrer ce que je disais sur la
france insoumise normalement quand vous
savez que vous avez près d'une trentaine
de points de participation de moins chez
les jeunes que chez les seniors c'est ce
qu'on voyait dans notre indicateur on
est autour des 70 % d'abstention chez
les jeunes et à seulement un peu plus de
40 chez les plus de 65 ans quand on est
à près d'une quinzaine et une vingtaine
de points de différence de
participations entre les foyers modestes
et les foyers les plus aisés ce qui est
est ce qu on mesurait dans le nôtre
indikar docteur d'abstention milieu de
semaine dernière ça pénalise la france
insoumise et le rassemblement national
aussi et pourtant dans notre indicateur
d'abstention on n'était qu'à 38%
chez les insoumis alors qu'on était à 40
% d'intentions de s'abstenir à heller
qui est pourtant normalement un parti
qui a un électorat plus participatif ça
veut dire quand même que jean luc
mélenchon a réussi et est en passe de
réussir ce pari là alors on va suivre ça
et puis on va sur sa formation parme
formation les enjeux quels sont les là
où il ya les curseurs qu'elle à quel
moment on pourra parler de pari réussi à
quel moment on pourra parler de victoire
parti et force par force bloc par bloc
un peu plus de 570 circonscription à
sont actuellement en jeu et ce sont
autant de données de graphiques de
résultats bien entendu qu'ils sont
traités avec beaucoup de talent et
d'imagination par les équipes du figaro
d'une équipe d'un service qu'on appelle
au figaro la figure out data autour de
stéphane saunier et c'est avec lui que
vous vous trouvez actuellement brune
d'audrey
weave ans auront comme vous l'avez dit
je suis donc juste devant le service
qu'on appelle le figaro data avec leur
chef donc stéphane joly bonsoir
j'aimerais savoir en quoi votre service
et un rouage essentiel lors d'une soirée
électorale alors tout simplement parce
que ces figues dattes à qui va recevoir
l'intégralité des données que ce soit en
lien avec le service politique jusque
dès 20h avec les estimations des
sondeurs que ce soit par la suite avec
le ministère qui va nous donner
l'intégralité des données et des
résultats définitifs avec lesquels on va
pouvoir produire des cartes des
infographies mais aussi des flash infos
qui vont être produits directement
depuis le service et qui vont nous
permettre d'avoir l'intégralité des
données à disposition des internautes
aussi notre moteur de recherche qui va
aussi être une une brique importante
pour que chaque internaute puisse
chercher les résultats dans sa
circonscription est-ce que vous pouvez
nous présenter un petit peu votre équipe
et le rôle de chacun ce soir alors oui
alors c'est une équipe très hétéroclite
dans ces profils donc on a à la fois
besoin de développeurs qui vont être le
rouage technique entre le ministère et
le site internet mais qui vont aussi
produire les différentes infographie
pour le site on va avoir des datas
journalistes qui vont faire par la suite
l'analyse de ces données pour en faire
des sujets des angles
et décrypter cette soirée électorale on
va avoir des rédacteurs et évidemment
des graphistes qui vont par la suite
reproduire ces infographies pour le
journal papier à disposition de nos
abonnés dès demain quel va être le défi
du fiqh data ce soir alors le défi je
pense qu'on a de le principal c'est
qu'il s'agit pas d'une seule élection
mais bien de 577 élections spécifique
donc ça c'est le premier défi à relever
c'est de s'assurer qu'on va bien pouvoir
traiter l'intégralité de ses données et
les restituer correctement bien
évidemment et le deuxième ça va être le
décompte alors on va mettre en place
nous avons mis en place sur le site un
décompte jusqu'à 20h qui va permettre de
dévoiler la nouvelle assemblée nationale
avec les premières estimations des
sondeurs merci beaucoup stéphane et bien
on scrutera donc avec attention sur
lefigaro.fr cette assemblée nationale
qui va se colorer en direct si j'ai bien
compris c'est avoue vincent roux alors
c'est exactement ça c'est vous allez
pouvoir suivre justement le remplissage
progressif de l'assemblée nationale et
c'est ça qui va être très intéressant à
suivre tout au long de la soirée on va
le faire ici en plateau et on le fera
également deuxième partie de soirée à
partir de 22h30 vous pourrez devant
demander d'ailleurs à thibaut gauthier
qui animera ce live quel est le résultat
dans votre commune dans les communes qui
vous sont chers et quel est le député ou
la députée qui a été élu dans votre
circonscription on revient sur un
chiffre 54% c'est le chiffre
l'abstention à claudius nous disait tout
à l'heure en substance que c'est en ne
faisant pas campagne et qui en n'ayant
pas de débat que emmanuel macron et lrm
son ont conduit à ce résultat
oui c'est une des explications c'est sûr
que
ils ont fait une campagne de défausse
il ya eu le fait que le président de la
république n'a quasiment pas fait
campagne pour l'élection sa réélection
son élection présidentielle et puis il
ya eu premier tour des législatives où
il n'a pas fait campagne du tout est
entre les deux tours ben je dirais il
est pas il a eu une séquence
internationale très importante puisqu'il
est allé en ville et à l'est notamment
en ukraine et c'est vrai que les thèmes
qui sont les thèmes qui préoccupent les
français qui sont les thèmes du pouvoir
d'achat qui sont des thèmes de
l'inflation qui sont les thèmes sur les
thèmes sociaux ah non pas du tout été
envisagée par le président de la
république et on sait simplement que il
doit adopter quelques mesures après
justement les élections législatives
donc c'est peut-être un des reproches
qui est fait au président de la
république mais pas uniquement y'a pas
que ce reproche là il ya probablement le
reproche d'une campagne enfin d'une
politique générale depuis cinq ans ba
qui ne convient pas une majorité de
français et une majorité de français qui
encore une fois on est dans le dégagisme
on continue le dégagisme 2017 je crois
que cette séquence là n'est pas terminé
on va partir maintenant de chaque
formation à l'assemblée la majorité
sortante actuellement donc c'est la
majorité présidentielle plus de plus de
300 députés si on comptabilise à la fois
lrm les alliés de modems et d'agir
l'enjeu c'est de faire bien évidemment
aussi bien cette fois-ci enfants tous
les cas de garder cette majorité absolue
ça paraît déjà hors de portée ça enfin
majorité absolue non mais pour répondre
à votre question de ferdinand d'abord
faire de 300 députés non mais vous dette
à 3 160 députés ça n'arrivera pas le au
delà des sondages réalisés dans
l'entre-deux-tours le seul résultat du
premier tour rend impossible cette
situation tout l'enjeu pour pour la
majorité ce soir c est ce qu'ils auront
la majorité absolue même à un ou deux
sièges près dans nos fourchettes c'est
possible mais c'est l'extrême limite
haute de la fourchette
alors que dans l'est dans les hypothèses
les plus basses on s'en éloigne
largement est-ce qu'ils auront une
majorité relative
relativement confortable leur permettant
de trouver des alliances avec quelques
divers gauche divers droite où est ce
qu'ils seront ce qui est très possible
très loin de la majorité relative
confortable et donc se retrouver à 250
ou 260 députés peut-être moins et là ce
sera très très compliqué donc tout
l'enjeu pour pour ensemble pour la
majorité présidentielle il est là ce
soir en plus est car il ya beaucoup de
sièges perdus et dès le premier tour et
il est démis certains ministres à tous
certains et certaines personnalités qui
sont quand même en posture pour le moins
très délicate bien sûr qu'ils étaient en
difficulté vous avez cité duster ameline
montchalin mais il ya également clément
bonne à paris vous aviez stanislas
guérini qui n'était pas dans une
situation facile
on évoqué tout à l'heure aussi le cas de
son pas ministre mais de richard ferrand
christophe castaner à tout 1 1 tab un
nombre de personnalités qui étaient en
difficulté
l'enjeu on le sait pour la majorité
c'était de récupérer 280 d'ivoire une
voix de plus que la majorité mais même
avec 290 voix ensemble
emmanuel macron n'échappait pas à une
difficulté qui était que ensemble vous
l'avez dit c'est l'heure c'est le
regroupement de l air m les maquereaux
nist du modem de françois bayrou et de
horizon des doigts philippe or on sait
depuis le 25 avril qu emmanuel macron ne
pourront plus se représenter vous avez
edouard philippe et et françois bayrou
qui ont le regard maintenant porté sur
2027 et pas sur quelles réformes ont
fait demain donc en réalité c'est une
majorité s'ils tentaient qu'elles soient
absolus ce soir qui aura été relative
avec la difficulté pour macron de devoir
négocier d'abord avec françois bayrou
edouard philippe ensuite si mm avec eux
ils n'ont pas la majorité absolue avec
d'autres ça soit des républicains et
républicains compatibles on sait qu'il y
en a il y en a qui n'ont pas eu de
candidat lrm face à eux
peut-être des socialistes venus de
lannux ça me paraît un peu compliqué
parce que quand vous avez été élu sur
une sorte de dynamique puisque malgré
tout même s'ils n'atteignent pas la
majorité absolue on sait bien que les
candidats de la nuque c'est au jour de
ce soir à partir de 20h ils iront on a
gagné parce qu'ils vont augmenter farce
forcément le bloc de gauche donc ça va
être dur de les décrocher actuellement 2
166 députés apparentés la république en
marche à l'assemblée à l'assemblée
nationale même ce score là pour donc le
parti présidentiel paraît très
difficilement atteignable ce soir et
l'enjeu également c'est pour horizon de
d'edouard philippe et bien sûr le modem
de faire plus et mieux que ce qu'ils
avaient fait la fois dernière mais là
aussi ça paraît difficile en tout cas
français louis basse que je pense que
dans la tête des français n'y a pas de
distinction volga tous à ccc pour pour
la plupart des français c'est du pareil
au même et c'est à dire que il ya une
majorité la majorité effectivement elle
a plusieurs composantes et je pense pas
que les français distingue edouard
philippe de deux des autres et
et en plus on va dire la vérité ils sont
tous inconnus en fin de vie ils sont
tous
pour la plupart d'entre eux des têtes
complètement inconnu du grand public
keith appartiennent à l'écurie bayrou à
l'écurie philippe pour l'écurie ou à
l'écurie présidentielle donc tout ça
ça ne s'est pas si vous laissez pas des
points supplémentaires dans la mesure où
maintenant emmanuel macron à je dirais a
des antécédents et bien cdc en décédant
le handicap lui et handicap ses troupes
alors qu' il était complètement vierge
il ya 5 ans ou 100 à force où sont
actuellement ou sont en tout cas au
premier tour les bastions de la majorité
l'ouest parisien ouais vous avez vous
avez les bastions classique du vote du
vote macron urbain et aisé
mais tout ça est éclatée exploser donc
au niveau au niveau national on aura
encore une carte des territoires qui va
être fragmenté et y compris dans des
territoires où ils étaient où il était
bien implanté manuel mâcon notamment
dans les zones urbaines de la région
parisienne mais maintenant concurrencer
par la nuit baisse c'est ça le
changement c'est de voir que on a on
avait un clivage territoriale entre le
rassemblement national d'un côté et la
majorité centrale centristes autour d'
emmanuel macron l'un étant dans les
villes l'autre dans les campagnes est
aujourd'hui dans les villes il est
concurrencé par un jean luc mélenchon il
n'y pas ce qu'ils font très fort c'est
chrome question aujourd'hui savait que
rien dire la réalité les a
on a grandi avec l'idée que les
hauts-de-seine s'était impasse tion du
rpr gestion sarkozyste
il ya vu un candidat elle est
aujourd'hui ce sera des candidats lrm
2017 paris le patient et les ruelles
raz-de-marée formidable d'ailleurs à tel
point que benjamin griveaux il fait bon
ben c'est simple on fait un copier
coller et puis je vais aux municipales à
paris je suis élu non catastrophe ça
n'est évidemment pas ça et aujourd'hui
ce n'est toujours pas ça on voit là
dedans législatives que la gauche a pris
sa revanche et on va voir peut-être ce
soir
une vague rose vin rouge sur paris donc
aujourd'hui la notion de bastion est
très compliqué à déterminer on s'est
peut-être trompé mais on s'est toujours
dit julien aubert vaucluse il est
implanté c'est un de ses bastions tout
résultat il est battu dès le premier
tour est assez sèchement ils arrivent
quatrièmes ben ouais il faut vraiment
valorisé bio j'arrivais cette idée de
bastions peut-être avant de rejoindre la
newsroom du figaro alors que on devrait
connaître des on espère connaître les
premières estimations dc dc 35 minutes
et je vous invite à rester avec nous car
le mode de scrutin on va y revenir
peut-être de des législatives réserve
peut réserver des surprises en tous les
cas c'est ce qui est c'est ce qui se
profile vous restez avec nous puisqu'on
en parle la nuque l'enjeu
est-ce que l'enjeu ça reste encore ce
soir la majorité et la victoire
tous les partis concourent pour la
victoire quoi qu'il arrive qu après il
ya un contexte et la nuque c'est
illusoire de penser qu'elle peut
remporter la majorité ni relais que la
majorité absolue la majorité absolue
même relatif ça serait quand même bien
rares ce qui est sûr c'est que
l'objectif aussi de jean luc mélenchon
s'installer à matignon paraît quand même
assez improbable donc l'objectif de la
nuque c'est de faire plus possible c'est
de restaurer cet esprit de gauche qui
avait disparu de la précédente de la
précédente assemblée avec 7
ce coût de ce coup de génie alors c'est
pas un coup de génie mais un coup de
bluff extraordinaire et qui peut se
concrétiser de jésus jean luc mélenchon
de faire en sorte c'est bien de faire de
restaurer le débat droite gauche à
l'assemblée nationale et d'avoir une
force de gauche qui sera une force alors
là c'est ça la particularité c'est que
généralement la gauche
elle était tiré par la gauche de
gouvernement par la gauche
sociale-démocrate et là c'est le dit
c'est différent c'est une l'extrême
gauche puisqu'il s'agit bien d'une
extrême gauche contrairement à tout ce
qu'on veut nous faire dire c'est une
extrême gauche qui tire la gauche
sociale-démocrate
105,75 autour de 75 80 députés
actuellement pour l'ensemble des gauches
de toute façon ils peuvent
majorité victoire ou pas m'en tous les
rêves et demi pas j'espère ils peuvent
espérer mieux ce serait quand même tenu
de leur très étonnant qu'ils ne les
droits obtenus de leurs résultats au
premier tour compte tenu de la dynamique
et qui est décrite dans toutes les
enquêtes un objectif qui serait un
triomphe ce serait de faire une centaine
de députés de plus et c'est tout à fait
à leur portée et si c'est pas une
centaine ça peut être un petit peu moins
mais ça c'est un objectif réaliste
crédible et qui changerait complètement
la donne surtout si ensemble était loin
d'avoir la majorité absolue ce serait un
pari gagné pour pour jean luc mélenchon
ils ont déjà réussi quelque chose c'est
au premier tour puisque c'est eux qui
ont eu le plus d'élus autres nettoie etc
des élus insoumis oui et la dynamique
qu'ils ont réussi à créer fait qu'il ya
un certain nombre de candidats qui et
dont on était à peu près sûr qu'ils
fassent récents sans problème le second
tour comme l'a dit c'est un très bon
coup politique de jean luc mélenchon
parce que au soir du second tour
d'élection présidentielle il aurait pu
disparaître après tout deuxième échec à
l'issue du premier tour
quelqu'un peut déjà âgée avec une gauche
qui était éclatée à cette époque là il
réussit l'incroyable le pari de réunir
tout le monde sous une bannière qui qui
qui permet à tout le monde de se dire
mais non je suis pas d'extrême gauche
regardez moi je suis je suis écologiste
moi je suis socialiste et c'est ça il a
réussi à maquiller l'extrême gauche dans
une gauche qui passe et
potentiellement
avec un résultat convard qu'on verra ce
soir qui peut être assez surprenant
est-ce qu'il peut bénéficier d'un autre
phénomène que vous avez pointé j'allais
dire dénoncé livre aux éditoriaux cette
semaine c'est le une forme pas
d'indulgence mais en tous les cas
d'ambiguïté de la part d'ailleurs 2 re
aiment dans les dents les appels à voter
pour le second tour wii u peut
bénéficier de ces trucs genre cela c'est
sûr que mais on verra aussi parce que
moi je pense que ça va bien au delà de
ça c'est indulgence que tout à fait
coupable et qui était pas du tout normal
quand on connaît le discours qui est
préexister qui a prévalu pendant des
années des années sur le front national
est sûre le rassemblement national et on
peut dire que la gauche de mélenchon
c'est une gauche qui n'est absolument
pas une gauche fréquentable on a bien
des points de vue et qui est champion
bien des points de vue dont il faut
dénoncer les combats
mais je dirais que cette mansuétude
c'est pas elle qui a fait le succès de
deux a le succès il faut le reconnaître
c'est d'abord le succès de jean luc
mélenchon ses succès d'une partie de son
entourage qui ont su trouver les mots
justes qui ont su réveiller une gauche
qui était vexé depuis des années des
années d'enregistrer des résultats
médiocres et donc même si c'est ce sont
des représentants qui ne plaisent pas à
tous les électeurs de gauche et loin
s'en faut eh bien ils permettent de deux
de survivre il permettre à la gauche de
survie
les chiffres il faut guetter pour pour
la nuque ou c'est un succès ou c'est un
échec de toute façon eu ce sera un
succès pour que ça on est tranquille il
y aura un succès de
succès
quel est le gros succès le long duc
c'est si vous doublez à peu près vous
rappeliez à vincent le nombre de députés
de gauche quand vous vous preniez
ensemble les ps les prg et les divers
gauche les les europe ecologie les verts
le pcf les filles il y a cinq ans vous
étiez à à 72 députés
mettons 75 pour faire un compte rond
vous doubler le score vous êtes à 150
c'est un c'est un beau succès
si vous allez au delà avec vous
augmentez d'une centaine le nombre de
députés présents à l'assemblée c'est
encore plus un succès et puis il ya
aussi un autre paramètre combien à
combien seront ils d'ensemble il faudra
regarder les blocs il vaut mieux pour
jean luc mélenchon politiquement et pour
la nuque baisse à voir ne pas atteindre
les 200 députés mais en revanche qu
ensemble face à un faible score est donc
se retrouver à faible distance
d'ensemble en termes de nombre de
députés et des clips politiques et puis
c'est un mécano cette assemblée parce
que si le rassemblement national fait
une entrée en masse à à l'assemblée ça
ça lui est prédit mais à quel point on
le verra on va dire ça ça peut avoir
aussi des conséquences parce que savard
en une chambre assez compliqué à gérer
quand même on va on va on va y revenir
sachant qu'il y a également d'autres
enjeux puisque pour l'instant la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale
était dirigée par exemple plus cher
ferrand et on a vu au premier tour
richard ferrand qui était dans une
position qui n'était pas tant qu'ils
étaient délicates alors qu'il a toujours
été lui réélu dans son dans son bastion
brestois oui et non il ya un vrai danger
si la marée est basse pour ensemble il
ya un vrai risque qu'un certain nombre
de deux têtes deux chefs de file ne
passe pas est ce que ce que dit gaël
sliman est très juste c'est à dire qu'il
ya un problème c'est que il est possible
on ne sait pas encore mais qui est une
chance qu'il soit un peu gouvernable ce
qui est assez incroyable avec ce mode de
scrutin qui est normalement a été mis là
en 58 pour permettre de dégager des
majorités une seule fois ça ne l'a pas
fait c'était 88 mais on peut dire que
c'était à l'appel du président de la
république qui avait dit il n'est pas
sain qu'un seul parti gouverné les
français avaient dû battre aucun aucun
problème on va suivre ton temps conseil
et là le parti socialiste et qu'il
n'avait prévu la majorité et il y avait
la proportionnelle au x mais permettait
justement choisi la c4 la locale sera
majoritaire le mail scrutin en boîte de
scrutin majoritaire et non il il faut
dire les choses c'est à dire que si
vraiment pour ensemble on est très en
dessous de la majorité absolue qu'il ya
un bras et la catastrophe
la question du maintien d isabelle borne
à matignon peut être posée parce qu'il
l'a il va falloir quand même l'évoquer
un premier ministre est politique c'est
à dire que l'assemblée nationale va
avoir un rôle à jouer qui va être
fondamental et pour rejoindre ce qu'ils
disent et yves c'est formidable parce
que c'est tout ce que ne veut pas
emmanuel macron c'est tout ce que n'est
pas imiter le maquereau en tout cas dans
les cinq premières années où il était
jupitérien où ils imposaient au fond
l'assemblée nationale c'était plutôt
quelque chose qui l'empêchait et il
demandait aux gens on appelait ça la
majorité playmobil bon vous obéissez
machin là ça ne pourrait pas être
possible et donc là il va falloir
discuter amender négocier et ce qui peut
le faire je ne sais pas alors on va
suivre ça dans un instant et on va vous
suivre ça dans un peu moins d'une demi
heure maintenant avec les premières
estimations vous restez avec nous c'est
une soirée qui promet de connaître
quelques rebondissements selon les
premières indications qui nous qui nous
parviennent une soirée qui sera en tout
cas très intéressante à suivre et elle
est traitée en première ligne à part le
ca par le web du figaro et en
particulier par cette page d'accueil
vous voyez ce player qui est dirigée
donc par qui est gérée par la home page
du figaro où se trouve actuellement
brune d'audrey
oui tout à fait et la homepage du figaro
et bien elle est gérée depuis cette
table ou plutôt ce bureau derrière moi
vous disais que c'est un rouage
essentiel puisque c'est ici que se
décide quel article est placé en
ouverture du figaro.fr et qu'elle
notification est envoyé à tous ceux qui
ont téléchargé notre application et à
quelle heure est avec moi donc le chef
d'orchestre frédéric frédéric picard bon
soit vous êtes rédacteur en chef au
figaro en charge de la tranche du soir
chef d'orchestre et ce c'est un peu
comme ça que je peux définir votre rôle
c'est oui c'est bien défini c'est ça
c'est on a des violoncellistes qui sont
brillants et on essaie de mettre tout ça
en musique pour ça et le plus vite
possible le mieux et informer nos
lecteurs en temps réel alors j'imagine
que ça fait beaucoup de soirées
électorales que vous chat potté pour le
figaro est-ce que la mécanique est bien
rodée est ce que vous nous la présenter
oui la mécanique est bien rodée on
essaie évidemment de d'être le plus
performant possible de donner les
informations le plus rapidement possible
et toujours vérifier c'est quand même la
clé de voûte de notre métier et pour ça
on organise une structure qui est assez
pensé très longtemps en amont pour être
à l'heure h présent tiens en parlant
d'heure jusqu'à quelle heure on va
pouvoir trouver des informations
fraîches actualisé au cours de cette
soirée le figaro et déjà ouverts 24
heures sur 24 figaro.fr est ouvert 24
heures sur 24 nous on quittera ici vers
2 heures du matin on va passer la main
aux états unis parce qu'on a des gens
aux états unis des collabore aux états
unis qui vont pouvoir agrémenté certains
papiers avec des réactions s'il y en a
et puis demain matin dès 5 heures
l'équipe de mario joseph sera là pour
reprendre la main et puis on est reparti
pour pour une journée qui s'annonce
assez importante merci beaucoup frédéric
picard je vous laisse travailler bon
courage à toutes les rédactions du
figaro pour cette soirée électorale
merci raphaël lazrag pour ces images et
quant à moi je vous retrouve tout de
suite en bas dans le grand studio du
figaro vincent oui on vous attend de
pied ferme
votre place et près de votre ordinateur
aussi et on va pouvoir scruter et suivre
les résultats
qui s'annonce un peu étonnant je ne vous
en dit pas plus pour l'instant de cette
soirée en tous les cas si nous en train
de nous parvenir se confirme on va
continuer à voir si vous voulez bien les
différentes les différents enjeux pour
les pour les différents blocs les
différents partis actuellement le
deuxième le premier parti d'opposition
le premier groupe d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale ce sont les
républicains ce qu'on sait c'est qu'ils
sont présentes maintenant dans 80
circonscriptions donc c'est beaucoup
moins que
l'ensemble a l'air eu des présents dans
80 circonscriptions c'est beaucoup moins
que le niveau actuel à l'assemblée
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent espérer ce soir
bas et ils peuvent espérer sauver la
mise parce qu'ils l'ont fait quand même
une présidentielle qui était
catastrophique où ils ont sont arrivés à
moins de 5% cette présidentielle a quand
même été une espèce de chaos
notes down vraiment terrible pour la
pole pour les républicains qui est quand
même le parti sous une appellation
différente qui a dominé l'histoire de la
vème république avec le parti socialiste
et c'était quand même très humiliant
alors
l'avantagent delà des républicains c'est
que c'est un parti qui est très bien
implanté sur le plan
local avec
la majorité dans beaucoup de deux
conseils départementaux dans beaucoup de
conseils régionaux avec quand même le
premier groupe d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale une centaine de
députés ils ont la majorité au sénat
c'est à dire qu'ils ont un maillage
vidéo logique et je dirais partisans qui
est quand même assez assez fort sur le
pays probablement le plus fort de tous
les partis compte tenu de cela ils
peuvent peut-être par des campagnes de
proximité et essayer de sauver la mise
espérer sauver la mise c'est à dire que
on leur prévoyait un destin à 25 30
députés mais compte tenu de leur ancrage
ils peuvent peut-être à espérer à être à
plus de 51 peser s'ils sont plus de 56
ans 60 ils poseront quand même dans la
vie politique et puis payson d'autant
plus que s'il ya une mergieux réalité
relais relatives aux le président de la
république le président de la république
aura tendance à se tourner vers eux pour
essayer de justement asseoir sa majorité
faire adopter des textes donc il
pourrait devenir un groupe charnière à
l'assemblée nationale troisième chose
qu'il faut pas oublier c'est que le
président de la république ne sera plus
l'art 2027 et que les républicains si
ils sont malins et si la jouent bien ils
peuvent espérer évidemment avoir un
candidat ce qu'ils ont quand même
d'aider des figures intéressante ils
peuvent peut-être espérer avoir un
candidat qui pèsera sur l'élection
présidentielle prochaine il n'est que
dans cinq ans un internaute disait mais
je comprends pas ce qui différencie
aujourd'hui
l'ailer drm car le but qui est un
allergologue
qu'est ce qui les différencie
j'ai combien de temps
elle peut faire quatre heures m selon
son voeu cet internaute la réponse est
rapide
sonica sécurité prenez la sécurité
prenaient le régalien par exemple les
laits retrouve que deux sur c'est sur
ces questions là il ya un impensé des
milieux macron il ya un vide ya une
sorte de trou noir c'est pas du tout la
préoccupation des manuels macron dans
son dernier quinquennat
j'allais dire ce qui s'est passé au
stade de france et la gestion par le
ministre de l'intérieur du chaos du
stade de france a apporté de l'eau au
moulin où l air en disant mais regardez
non seulement ils s'en occupent pas mais
en plus ils dénient il nie la réalité
premier exemple en matière économique
vous pouvez aussi prendre des exemples
sur sa serai là peut-être plus plus
nuancé parce que sur la retraite c'est
ils sont ils en sont pas loin le projet
de valérie pécresse est le projet avant
qu'il soit amendé d'emmanuel macro était
à peu près pareil sur un report de l'âge
légal à 65 ans
le problème c'est que en politique il
faut que vous créez un chemin
les élèves qui sont restés là la plupart
d'entre eux seront élus après avoir
affronté un un candidat ensemble donc
est ce qu'ils voudront participer à une
majorité
qui intègre un ensemble c'est pas
évident une partie d'entre eux ont
convaincu la gauche peut-être leur
assemblée nationale donc là ça sera
peut-être plus facile mais la réalité ce
que disait il est très juste c'est que
ils vont être là un groupe charnière
mais avec un rôle fondamental est ce
qu'ils prendront la position de mots que
bruno retailleau a exprimé ce matin dans
le jdd qui est en gros banon n'est pas
compatible non on va pas avec emmanuel
macron et sa majorité où est ce qu'ils
seront plus souples à la manière d'un
nicolas sarkozy disant d'ailleurs dans
le figaro et pas d'autre solution à la
question subsidiaire est-ce que c'est
pas un risque d'éclatement peau à l'air
bien sûr il ya un risque d'éclatement il
sera peut-être moins fort s'ils
reviennent plus nombreux que ce que l'on
le ce qu'on leur promettait certes ils
auront moins de députés que la
législature précédente c'était un peu
plus de sens mais on leur a promis les
mines de sel c'était en gros si vous
revenez à 20 ou 30 estimez vous heureux
s'ils ont le double et un peu plus ce
soir je veux dire on entendra un ouf de
soulagement dans toute la france leur
côté
[Rires]
effectivement sachant quand même parfois
en un mot sur la sphère des bastions
mais c'est quand même un des phénomènes
de ses premiers tours cette élimination
dans dans des régions où les pensées
mais enraciné dans le sud
est et dans les yvelines mais ils
peuvent se reconstituer alors je vais
pas me contredire parce que j'ai dit que
les bastions n'existait plus ils peuvent
se reconstituer des fiefs regarder le
score d'aurélien pradié dans le dans le
lot à cahors est une terre de gauche
sachant qu'il a 7 ans et une est le
département où l'on vote le plus vous
faites un lien entre les
jeunes ont je sais pas en tout cas je
fais le lien avec un aurélien pradié qui
a travaillé sa circonscription qui
faisait visiblement ça a plu à ses
électeurs un dernier enjeu pour les
républicains le grand enjeu ce sera à
quel point ils seront les faiseurs de
roi c'est ce qu'il se disait c'est ce
qu'on pensait en regardant les résultats
du premier tour en voyant les
projections d'entre deux tours en se
disant
même en recul et ils seront recul c'est
une certitude même avec une cinquantaine
une soixantaine de députés ce qu'on
pouvait avoir dans nos projections et
même s'ils font un peu mieux il y aura
un recul en revanche si la majorité
présidentielle est loin de la majorité
absolue avec toutes les réserves que
vous avez tous les deux rappelé les
difficultés de concilier les contraires
ils seront le faiseur de voir parce que
c'est le seul parti qui pourraient
globalement trouver des alliances quitte
à ce que ce soit ponctuellement vous
savez que emmanuel macron se positionne
comme étant et de droite et de gauche
est globalement quand on parlait de
différence sur le plan économique il
peut y avoir beaucoup de proximité entre
les souhaits les aspirations dlr est ce
que peut souhaiter ou voir un emmanuel
macron donc sur les grandes réformes
économiques comme la réforme des
retraites ou d'autres ils pourront
trouver des désaccords sur les réformes
sociétales ils auront sans doute plus de
mal et l'a peut-être que emmanuel macron
pour passer devra essayer de se tourner
vers sa gauche si on en est bien là ce
soir est de toute façon ils seront le
parti central dans la prochaine majorité
ce qui va devoir être suivi à mon avis
attentivement ces qui va être président
du groupe ça va être le rôle fondamental
parce qu'il va falloir tenir le gros et
surtout tenir
au sein d'une taille qui est redoutable
il est possible que ce soir le groupe de
rassembler nationale et plus de députés
que le groupe ait l'air ça vous fait une
pression tu es pour l'instant c'était
parce qu'ils étaient dans l'est dans les
différentes stations se trouvent alors
c'est pas ses sources à se croiser dans
les dents les pros dans les fourchettes
ces fourchettes les haut de fourchette
et rennes étaient près d'une
cinquantaine les bas de fourchette et
l'air à une quarantaine et ça ne pouvait
monter à plus de 60 pour l'un et ça
pouvait descendre beaucoup plus bas pour
l'autre avec il n'y a plus de front
républicain notre sondage de milieu de
semaine l'a montré l'appel au front
républicain s'est fait totalement de
shit et ça ce sera peut-être ce quelque
chose c'est le challenge réservé ans
passés voilà c'est un c'est un enjeu
important la pression des députés rennes
sera énorme de voter avec la majorité
avec vous êtes donc favorable à la
majorité électoralement sur le terrain
ça fait dur et al'inverse on voit très
bien ce que vont dire les membres et
edouard philippe françois bayrou tant
sur les nerfs autre pression parce que
l'art même s'ils n'ont pas la majorité
absolue il y aura un groupe assez
important qui diront r vous savez pas
votez avec le rassemblement national on
sait pas faire ça bon si vous faites ça
ça veut dire donc il va falloir là un
président de groupe et qui s'associe
avec une équipe qui soit assez solide je
vous rappelle les chiffres de
l'abstention en tous les cas les
estimations pour l'instant autour de 54
% donc une abstention qui serait
supérieur à ce qu'on a pu voir au
premier tour mais
qui serait un peu moindre par rapport à
2010 c'est tout ce chiffre avait dépassé
les 57 % une des questions d'ailleurs ça
va être les reports de voir de voir
quels ont été les reports d'un tour à
l'autre ce qui me permet de faire la
transition en saluant bruno devrait dire
que cette fois ci on a le plaisir
d'avoir schaller nasa bonjour à vous
bonjour à tous
pardonnez moi de parler justement un
petit peu de météo mais il me semble que
bon nombre de français citadins ont
quitté les villes sous cette chaleur
écrasante week-end il reste une question
est-ce qu'ils sont tous rentrés à temps
pour aller voter et est ce que on peut
craindre que l'abstention justement ne
joue en faveur d'un parti ou d'un autre
carl meeus alors le premier qui a été au
milieu de ceux qui rentraient mais voilà
essayer de venir
essayer de rentrer ce qu'ils essayaient
de rentrer pour voter ça c'est une bonne
question je n'ai pas la réponse
c'est sur que c était un des enjeux
notamment dans les grandes villes pour
les municipales nicolas florian par
exemple attributs nettement sa défaite
en partie au bassin d'arcachon oui c'est
très difficile à savoir vous savez la la
la la la météo à une quand même une
incidence relative sur le
vote des français il ya un exemple un
précédent célèbre 7983 la victoire au
premier tour d'alain carignon nous avons
municipal à grenoble qui défait du
bedous qui était le maire quasi mythique
de la cité alpine et tout le monde était
parti skier mais parce qu'il faisait un
temps magnifique que toulon était parti
skier on avait attribué à la météo la
défaite du bo d'où ce qui était
d'ailleurs pas très sympathique pour
alain carion
seul août évolué par la suite le oui qui
a été réélu par la suite mais bon
toujours est il que je crois que c'est
très marginal si vous voulez et
d'ailleurs si on a un chiffre de 56 % de
2,2 d'abstention en 1 54 54 eur
d'abstention
c'est grosso modo je vais me comprenant
20 jours donc c'est pas il y aura de
quoi si vous voulez attribuer sa
déraison ils sont des raisons autres que
celles qu'on connaît menace d'un point
de vue programmatique est-ce que la
canicule les fortes chaleurs dont on a
beaucoup parlé ces derniers jours c'est
un des joueurs à jouer en faveur d'un
programme en particulier aux pensées je
serais étonné je pense que quand on
regardait les motivations des
abstentionnistes et des électeurs a
priori on est loin on est loin de ces
considérations là donc si alors si
l'ensemble fait un mauvais score comme
cela lui est promis ne manqueront pas
d'expliquer que leur électorat bourgeois
urbains étaient partis en grand week end
se réfugier je crois que ca proviendra
d'autres choses
l'autre enjeu sur l'abstention c'est ce
qu'on se disait c'est de savoir quelles
vont être les reports de voix
en tout cas ce ceux qui se sont abstenus
et qui ont voté au premier tour et puis
ceux qui ont voté au premier tour dont
les candidats n'ont pas été au second
tour oui c'est tout l'enjeu dans les
matrices de qui sont utilisés par les
instituts pour faire les projections en
sièges dans l'entre-deux tours on
utilise ces matrices de reports de voix
et on se rendait compte que il y avait
des choses parfois assez surprenante
l'élément clé c'est l'absence de front
républicain c'est à dire que quand on a
un candidat du fn face à un candidat
ensemble ou face à un candidat du ps
la plupart des autres électeurs de
premier tour s'en fiche éperdument et
disent je reste à la maison et
n'appellent pas et ne suivent pas les
appels au vote donc globalement
on risque d'avoir des surprises sur les
reports de voix qui auront eu lieu entre
les candidats de premier tour et ceux
qui sont qualifiés aujourd'hui en finale
on devrait connaître une première
tendance d'ici une douzaine de minutes
maintenant vous restez avec nous des
premières estimations des premières
tendances nous parviennent alors c'est
pas forcément ce que vous dites dans lé
chat et je vous remercie ray si vous
participez de garde et de respecté le
silence électoral le silence
démocratique avant de 20h les seuls
estimations fiables qui vont être donnés
sur les estimations les premières
estimations qui sont donnés par les
instituts de sondage et bien sûr celles
qui seront confirmés à partir de 20h et
pas forcément celle qu'on peut trouver
ailleurs notamment dans l'est dans les
sites étrangers
donc pour l'instant
vous restez avec nous on continue de
débattre on continue de commenter on
continue de réagir on va examiner un des
derniers enjeux de cette élection on en
parle depuis le depuis le début oui tout
à fait mais avant ça je salue pascal
brucci qui me dit bonjour dans le tchat
sur notre page youtube flickr relève
alors bonjour avoue pascal qui rebondit
sur ce que vous disiez à les huîtres
d'arcachon inévitable danser dans les
législatives et lionel au dos totalement
une explication sur les matrices de
reports des voix qu est ce que c est ce
que c'est un outil mathématique
peut-être gaël ce que vous pouvez nous
éclairer notre intérêt oui les matrices
d'euros ce qu'une bonne question déjà
les matrices de reports de voix c'est un
nouvel élan goku well et on a les
résultats du premier tour et dans
chacune des circonscriptions les
instituts de sondages qui font ces
projections en sièges demande aux
personnes interrogées ce qu'elle compte
faire dans leur circonscription pour le
second tour alors les matrices ont assez
simple quand vous avez voté au premier
tour pour ensemble ou pour nubes en
général vous re voter pour eux mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir quel
va être le comportement des électeurs
aient l'air si on est par exemple dans
une circonscription où il ya un duel
entre ensemble et nous paie ce que font
les électeurs à l'air que font les
électeurs des autres candidats et c'est
à partir de ces matrices de reports on
reprocher ensuite sur les 577
circonscriptions pour avoir une idée en
fourchette très large de ce que ça peut
donner donc inutile de vous dire que
c'est beaucoup plus de travail que
d'habitude pour avoir un résultat
beaucoup moins précis puisque les
projections en sièges même en fourchette
large il suffit qu'une matrices de
reports vous disent que les candidats
aient l'air dans les circonscriptions de
ce type là de cette catégorie là se
reporteront à 60% sur ensemble par
exemple et puis qu'en fait il ya une
petite marge d'erreur c'est pas 60 c 55
parce qu'on ne peut pas être dans toutes
les circonscriptions et à ce moment là
vous pouvez avoir vingt députés qui
allait pour l'un qui bascule pour
l'autre donc c'est un travail fastidieux
sur le plan statistique sérieux
rigoureux mais qui aboutit en gène qui
aboutit en réalité à avoir des
fourchette assez large et d'essai niveau
de certitude assez faible
alors est donc ce qui nous mène
justement au pouvoir d'achat oui
peut-être pouvoir d'achat
et peut-être mais ses connexes avec le
pouvoir d'achat puisque il ya un blog
qu'on n'a pas étudié et qu'on n'a pas
regardé qui a été un peu le le perdant
de la campagne du premier tour c'est le
rassemblement national
est-ce que c'était chronique d'une
défaite annoncée ce qui peut y avoir des
surprises ce soir autour du racing alors
oui déjà parce que le rassemblement
national est présent dans de très très
nombreuses circonscriptions au second
tour on as assez fréquent
oui mais pas à ce point et dans des
configurations de triangulaire où tout
ce qu'il peut espérer habituellement
c'est de faire perdre les adversaires et
moins de pouvoir gagner lui même donc
les surprises sur le rassemblement
national qui est créditée au mieux d'une
cinquantaine de députés elles peuvent
être importantes il peut faire beaucoup
mieux le rassemblement national parce
que mais parce que dans les dents les
fameux sondages d'entre deux tours ce
que l'on voit c'est que la part des
français qui nous disent être fidèle au
front républicain je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure est à peu près nulle et que bien
souvent des électeurs vous disent mais
pour moi c'est blanc bonnet blog bonnet
blanc que d'avoir un match entre le nu
paix crn ou entre ensemble et rn et je
préfère rester à la maison par ailleurs
on observe aussi d'assez bons reports de
l air vers le rassemblement national ce
qui est plutôt inhabituel
donc ils peuvent créer une surprise ce
soir un report de voix et rennes
également sur une baisse c'est possible
c'est très foncée quasi il existait une
question qui tombe beaucoup sur ensemble
à tanger vers l'est
alors c'est pas tant que ça ça existe
mais au global mans vous avez à peu près
du trois tiers sur de l'électorat qui a
voté au premier tour pour le
rassemblement national et pour lequel le
rn ne seraient plus présents dans la
circonscription c'est un tiers je
m'abstiens un tiers je vote pour
ensemble par exemple si c'est la
configuration ensemble du ps et un tiers
pour nubes est en réalité ça va être
même un peu plus ne pèse qu ensemble
mais globalement ça annule
les reports de voix et rennes c'était ce
qu'on observait avant on verra ce soir
ils veulent en jeu pour le et rennes ce
soir c'est de faire le plus comme les
hawks est de faire le plus de députés
possible à mon avis si ils arrivent à
dépasser que le rn n'a pas de groupe à
l'assemblée nationale depuis justement
aux objectifs dont il avait eu un groupe
parce qu'ils avaient une trentaine le
député en 1986 parce que c'était à la
proportionnelle s'ils arrivent à
dépasser ce chiffre avec un scrutin
uninominal qui compte d'autres ont dit
qu'ils ne leur est pas favorable moi ça
va être la grosse question ce soir ça
sera un bon résultat la grosse question
ce soir c'est est ce que justement ce
scrutin qui est régulièrement remise en
question en disant 'il est pas
représentatif ils empêchent l'a si
justement vous avez une assemblée
nationale qui est éclatée à tout le
monde pas ranger sa gaule va dire bah
finalement on y arrive aussi comme ça
alors et comme c'est comme quoi ya pas
de se représenter sur la gouvernabilité
rade bon mode de scrutin
ce mode de scrutin partir quand on est
implanté et qu on laboure le terrain et
qu'on respecte ses électeurs on arrive à
se faire élire alors que le
rassemblement national généralement
baissé les bras après l'élection
présidentielle
est ce qu'un rassemblement national fort
peut
attirer une partie
de l'ain groupe lr qui serait travaillé
par soit à une alliance avec avec le le
bloc présidentiel où la majorité
présidentielle est de rester fidèle
c'est le positionner leurs en tout cas
il va chercher à les aimante et
stratégiquement à l'assemblée
normalement bon et dans l'arène est à
l'extrême droite et évidemment il va
coller les députés aient l'air donc un
président de groupe un peu futés va
mettre sur les bons à côté des arènes
des gens qui sont étanches comme ça pour
éviter parce que c'est souvent on
discute comme une autre à prades il ya
un moment on a des affinités se créent
tout ça évidemment qu'il va y avoir ils
vont chercher à les aimante et surtout
si le groupe et rennes est plus
important que le groupe ait l'air parce
que là vous aurez une masse ça va donner
des moyens on le sait un groupe c'est
des moyens des moyens matériels des
moyens financiers des moyens humains
ça va compter moi ce qui j'ai trouvé
très intéressant c'est un ils font un
bon score quand même au premier tour
peut-être là au second avec un nombre de
députés qui va être important alors même
que marine le pen n'a pas fait campagne
pour en découdre c'est à dire elle peut
se mordre les doigts si jamais elle
avait fait campagne qu'est ce que ça
aurait donné premiers points 2e point
vous voyez une extension du front du
rassemblement national sur le sud ouest
je reviens n'y a pas d'autres études on
a appris par le sud-ouest c'était la
résistance l'ouest le sud-ouest
résistent est culturellement gelé dire
honte aux logiquement au front national
ce n'est plus le cas vous avez tout une
housse est un board charente maritime
gironde tarn tarn et garonne on arrive
sur les pyrénées et sur l'arc
méditerranéen où là c'est classique
tout ça ça s'est refusé et ça serait
très intéressant de voir sur quelles
motivations vous l'évoquiez tout à
l'heure c'est pas seulement
l'immigration ça peut être aussi le
pouvoir d'achat ça peut être
des gilets jaunes des gens qui se disent
on va passer maintenant et au fn si
c'est le cas ça veut dire que là ils ont
semé pour dans cinq ans brahim el
cookies justement sur le chat qui nous
fait part de son avis je comprends pas
pourquoi voter pour le front national le
rn ils ont fait quoi à l'assemblée
pendant cinq ans quasiment rien
franchement les appâtant entendu dans
l'hémicycle est ce que c'est parce qu'il
n'avait pas de groupe justement est là
maintenant il n'existait convalescent
voilà c'est à dire que par rapport à
cette question par la réponse que
donnerait les électeurs et rennes ou
ceux qui en sont proches et 1 il n'était
pas représenté par ce que il évoquait le
système électoral qui est hautement
préjudiciables jusqu'à ce soir il a
toujours puni les formations qui n'était
pas taillé pour ce scrutin à deux tours
et c'était le cas du rassemblement
national ça le sera peut-être encore un
petit peu mais vraisemblablement moins
qu'avant et puis une deuxième raison qui
pousse à les gens à voter et rennes et
extrême gauche c'est qu'à un moment
donné quand même faut rappeler qu
emmanuel macron a créé une si cette
situation il a créé une situation où il
a ventilé façon pujol la gauche
classique le ps classique de
gouvernement et il a fait pareil avec la
droite de gouvernement et il le il a
expliqué en gros que c'était soit lui
soit les extrêmes eh bien c'est ce à
quoi on assiste maintenant ça c'est une
prophétie auto réalisatrice
on se retrouve avec globalement des
forces politiques où vous avez des
forces centrales avec une droite
potentiellement supplétives l air et
puis une extrême gauche et extrême
droite nous sommes en ce pays là
aujourd'hui ce qui est intéressant tous
les cas dans ce que vous avez dit ça
c'est un des phénomènes qu'on va devoir
observer la maintenant dans un petit peu
plus d'une minute c'est que le front
républicain n'a pas été en tous les cas
n'a n'a pas n'a pas trouvé d'adhésion
dans l'électorat selon les sujets soit
vous donner un exemple un an que doivent
faire les candidats de la nuque est
éliminé au premier tour en cas de second
tour face à la majorité présidentielle
et le rassemblement national on a
seulement un quart des français qui nous
disent ils doivent appeler à voter pour
le candidat de la majorité
présidentielle et c'est à peu près les
mêmes la même chose quand on pose la
question inverse que doit faire le
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
lorsqu'il a été éliminé et qui a un duel
entre nubes crn donc chacun rentre à la
maison et il n'y a pas de raison de
penser plus werlen que vers l'autre
c'est pas du tout ce qui s'était passé
il ya vingt ans quand jean marie le pen
avait été au second tour de la
présidentielle c'est un changement total
de pas de paradis il est 19 heures 59
maintenant donc est presque 30 secondes
donc en moins de 30 secondes on saura
qui est arrivé en tête du second tour de
ces élections législatives 2022 et quels
seront les couleurs de la future
assemblée nationale jean luc mélenchon
va t'il à réussir son pari et l'herbe et
il l'est républicain vente il a comme le
disait tout à l'heure il sauver les
meubles qui sera le premier parti
d'opposition à emmanuel macron
5 5 secondes on est en mesure de vous
montrer à quoi va ressembler cette
nouvelle assemblée nationale
accrochez vous il ya des surprises
arrivent en tête donc ensemble avec
entre 210 et 250 députés pour l'instant
sur les premières estimations 150 à 180
pour la nuque suivi de l est rude et y
60 à 70 et là surprise plus de députés
donc pour le rassemblement national plus
de députés que la droite traditionnelle
avec 80 à 100 sièges pour la future
assemblée nationale une première
réaction ce soir des sondages c'est
selon les estimation d'ipsos mais
peut-être dix fois pardon excusez moi si
les cendres je reprends ce sont des
estimations d'ifop mais gaël peut-être
juste rapidement une précision après
tout les instituts donnent de neige dans
ces étiages là c'est à dire que là vous
avez une une majorité présidentielle qui
fait encore moins que les mauvais scores
dont elles étaient déjà crédités dans
les derniers sondages d'entre deux tours
et que ce qui se profile au premier tour
donc c'est une aggravation de la
situation malgré tout elle est en
majorité relative la première formation
politique encore heureux me direz-vous
pour pour emmanuel macron et la grosse
surprise c'est évidemment le score du
rassemblement national
avec 80 à assen certains sont 12 sur ces
étiages là 80 90 députés soit en gros
une vingtaine et une trentaine de plus
que ce qui était promis au et rennes on
va on vient de voir les images réaction
au siège de la nuque enfin l'enjeu ce
soir yves c'est de savoir si les
insoumis il rassemble si les insoumis or
en plus de députés que le rassemblement
national ou pas oui exactement alors
effectivement que ce qu'à l'intérieur de
la nuque de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale il ya
effectivement les insoumis le parti de
jean luc mélenchon mélenchon et ça
serait cocasse de voir que le
rassemblement national est plus
important que
les insoumis et ça serait d'une certaine
façon une claque pour les insoumis
d'ailleurs parce que ça voudrait dire
que les grands vainqueurs en dépit du
fait qu'elle ait pas fait campagne alors
qu'est ce que ça aurait fait si elle
avait fait campagne comme le disait tout
à l'heure karl et bien les grands
vainqueurs c'est le rassemblement
national ce soir et encore une fois avec
un mode de scrutin dont on ne va pas
arrêter de dire qu'il n'était pas du
tout adaptée alors à leur action
politique eh bien il va falloir réviser
sérieusement tout ça car les
commentaires
grosse désillusion pour l' ensemble
royal macron qui va devoir se poser des
questions souvent regardés en
l'organisation les chiffres de sa
majorité il n'a pas la majorité absolue
les projections aucune projection ne
donne au delà de 250 260 donc la
majorité absolue est de 189 en revanche
si on peut si on veut être taquin et on
peut l'être ici
si vous additionnez les députés ensemble
et député divers droite et député ehlers
a fait une majorité absolue ce que c'est
ce que veulent les gens d'ensemble les
gens de l r je n'en suis pas sûr mais
voilà s'il ya une recherche de majorités
absolues pour l'instant c'est le seul
bloc le l'autre élément là qui concerne
la vie parlementaire proprement dite et
l'avis de l'assemblée nationale vous
savez que depuis la réforme de 2008 la
présidence de la commission des finances
revient à l'opposition jusqu'ici tout le
monde est excité la gauche qui veut
l'emporter si le rn est le premier parti
d'opposition je ne doute pas qu'ils
réclament cette présidence on voit à
l'instant d'ailleurs les
les images il me semble que c'est à
hénin beaumont c'est à hénin beaumont où
marine le pen est annoncée selon les
estimations notamment d'harris
interactive réélu avec plus de 60% des
voix marine le pen qui avait obtenu
d'ailleurs au premier plus de 50% mais
qui n'avait pas exigé pas assez
d'électeurs pour qu'elle soit considérée
vainqueur d
le premier tour claudius nous dit le à
rennes devient dangereux et
c'est potentiellement en tous les cas
la grande surprise de ce soir est
finalement quelque chose qui est assez
conforme à la tendance générale du pays
c'est le deuxième parti de france c'est
ça sert qu'en fait ce que je crois il
disait et carlo si on se retrouve avec
un système qui n'est quand même pas
faits pour produire une bonne
représentativité fin
normal c'est un miracle ou s'éteint
normalement ça ne produit pas de
représentativité et c'est bien pour ça
que les gens le dénonce un sur s'arrache
les cheveux par poignées quand ils sont
électeurs d'extrême gauche ou d'extrême
droite et qu'il dise non à peser 20 %
les élections n'existe plus à
l'assemblée et là on se retrouve avec
quelque chose d'un peu plus conforme à
ce qu'est la réalité du pays dans les
divers élections notamment la
présidentielle dans son premier tour de
législatives déjà et encore ce serait
pas cher payé puisque le rn avec moins
de 100 députés c'est moins que ce qu'il
représente dans dans le temps dans le
pays réel en termes d'élections mais ce
serait une assemblée assez incroyable ce
serait on en parle au conditionnel c'est
une assemblée même si les projections
vont s'affiner même si ça bouge encore
d'une dizaine d'une vingtaine de députés
ici ou là c'est une c'est une assemblée
tout à fait incroyable avec une seule
majorité possible on le disait avant
mais c'est encore plus confirmer
maintenant c'est une des décisions qui
ne pourront se faire la majorité contre
ensemble et l air avec les divers droite
ce qui promet de la colère parce que
notamment sur les réformes économiques
pourquoi le pays a autant voter pour
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
pourquoi les gens ont voté à ce point
pour les insoumis pour le rassemblement
national parce que notamment que ce soit
au premier tour de la présidentielle où
c'est sûr lors des précédents ce que tu
as parce que notamment ils sont contre
certaines des réformes économiques que
veut porter emmanuel macron et qu'il a
présentée dans l'entre-deux tours et
notamment la réforme des retraites la
réforme des retraites on imagine
aisément ensemble et l air se mettent
d'accord pour faire une réforme rapide
forte mais que dire on lève tous ces
français qui ont voté exactement contre
ça ce sera un autre sujet ce qu'il peut
faire un manuel macron soir
on va voir ça va être intéressant de
voir ce qu'il va faire
c'est une un revers une défaite pour lui
importante
historique je dirais pas ça parce que
c'est pas vrai
patron il ya cinq ans sur la scène
politique dans ses pays historiques mais
c'est un revers et ça va compliquer
considérablement sa tâche il ya plein de
questions qui vont se poser c'est de
savoir si effectivement les républicains
vont pas lui mener la vie dure parce
qu'avec 50 70 députés et bien quand il
va aller les chercher pour voter des
textes ils vont peut-être posé des
conditions qui sont des conduites
conditions extrêmement
difficiles à accepter ou qui seront
d'une grande exigence et à ce moment là
pour lui ça sera pas simple
une espèce de déception j'imagine du
côté de chez mélenchon quand même parce
que il nous a rabattu les oreilles
pendant des semaines et des semaines et
puis finalement on s'aperçoit que le
rassemblement national toutes
proportions gardées fait peut-être mieux
que lui beaucoup mieux que lui même et
donc s'il est on à rassemblement
national avec pas loin de 100 députés ce
cas un phénomène incroyable ça veut dire
que cette élection a été marqué par ça
et le rassemblement national peut très
bien effectivement donné la commission
des finances la présidence de la
commission des finances donc le
rassemblement national va aussi beaucoup
pesé sur la
vie de l'assemblée ce qui est sûr c'est
que cette nouvelle assemblée si on on
est dansé dans ce schéma là est un peu
le produit de ce qui s'est passé
finalement pendant ce quinquennat c'est
à dire qu'il ya eu le mouvement des
gilets jaunes avec une une radicalité
discours qu'ils soient de droite ou de
gauche il ya eu la crise sanitaire dont
la gestion n'a pas été n'a pas eu l'heur
de plaire à tout le monde
il ya comme ça une une insatisfaction de
la part d'une grande partie des français
entre ceux qui se sont abstenus et ceux
qui se sont réfugiés dans des votes je
dirais reste quand même des votes à ces
protestataires eh bien on a une
photographie de la france
elisabeth bord d'un premier résultat
qu'on peut vous annoncer donc qui qui a
été élu dans sa circonscription du
calvados avec
52,3 pour cent des voix selon des
estimations de l'ifop donc elle a battu
le candidat de la nuque mais ce qui est
à 47 7 ça veut dire qu'elle va être
confortée dans son dans ses positions
car loup malgré là le petit score de
ensemble il ya un remaniement un
changement de premier ministre à
l'horizon alors remaniement de toute
façon oui puisque déjà on sait que enfin
on sait on peut imaginer vu le nombre de
députés qui vont revenir à l'assemblée
qu'il ya des ministres qui vont rester
au tapis puisque on voit bien que la la
vague est pas très haute et on certains
ministres étaient en position très
délicate
et il avait deux bornes a été nommé au
lendemain de la présidentielle sur une
idée d' emmanuel macron qu'il fallait
parler à la gauche
aujourd'hui on voit bien que s'il veut
une majorité absolue il doit compter sur
la droite c'est pas auprès de la nuque
qui va pouvoir compter des voix quand il
va devoir faire passer des textes ou
alors ils auront vraiment beaucoup
changé entre l'élection et et
l'assemblée et donc est ce qu elisabeth
borne est la mieux placée pour discuter
avec les verts première question
deuxième question qui déjà apparaissait
auprès de certains proches des mineurs
macron la semaine dernière qui était qu'
il va falloir quelqu'un de très
politique parce que déjà il sentait
qu'il n'aurait pas une majorité absolue
il n'imaginait pas être aussi bas et
donc la question était qui sera le guy
carcassonne des mailheuls macro guerre
car ce alors il se disait qu'il paye car
quel voilà le conseiller de michel
rocard 2,88 à 91 qui négociaient pour
lui tous les textes et il en a pas c'est
quand même quand on se sent souviens
c'est pas des textes faciles la création
de la csg et la suprême le retour de l'
isf et d'autres comme ça et il prenait
son bâton de pèlerin il allait négocier
de temps en temps avec les centristes en
temps avec les communistes certes cette
est facilitée parce qu'à l'époque il
pouvait passer les textes grâce à
l'article 49-3 autant qu'il le voulait
cette fois ci c'est plus possible on n'a
le droit qu'à un seul 49,3 par session
si on exclut le vote du budget le vote
du père fss et donc ça va pas très loin
donc il faut quelqu'un qui va pouvoir
discuter
trouver
un chemin parce que c'est ça la
politique trouve un chemin d'entente
gaël sliman l'évoqué tout à l'heure sur
les retraites est ce qui est un choix
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui peut
passer sinon on risque fort d'être dans
un quinquennat où il ne se passera rien
parce que rien ne pourra éviter c'est
moins ce qu'on espérait a admis donc
gabriela talent chez nos confrères de
tf1 ce soir il a déclaré les français ne
nous ont pas donné de majorité absolue
c'est une situation inédite qui va nous
imposer de dépasser nos certitudes et
nos clivages
gaël sliman c'est moins ce qu'on
espérait c'est beaucoup moins ou un
petit peu moins on était à quel type de
sondage c'est beaucoup alors c'est
beaucoup moins que ce qu'ils espéraient
puisque il espérait probablement avoir
la majorité absolue
certains confrères dans
l'entre-deux-tours en fourchette haute
donc déjà ce qui s'annonce être sentais
pas très bon quand même en fourchette
haute chez certains confrères on était à
3 cents nous on était sur la fourchette
la plus basse pour ensemble avec en bas
de fourchette 252 là on va voir ce qui
sort mais je crois qu'on est encore un
peu en deçà ou dans leurs différentes
projections à arthur berda je reste au
service politique du figaro vient de
faire un calcul entre 200 et 260 pour
ensemble donc l'enjeu il a fait la
moyenne des différents des neiges
l'allemagne à l'influente sénatrice
ipsos ifop opinionway donc ça fait deux
cent trente environ à venir 20 de moins
que le pire de ce qu'il pouvait imaginer
c'est très loin du meilleur de ce qu'il
pouvait pensez donc c'est effectivement
mais c'est pas mal ce que la réaction de
gabriel attal est assez juste parce que
bon dire que c'est moins ça c'est assez
évident mais c'est ce qu'il dit ensuite
qui est intéressant ça va les obliger à
dépasser leurs certitudes ça signifie
exactement ce que disait karl qu'il
faudra dans le remaniement injecter de
la politique de la discussion du débat
le parlement va avoir la bonne nouvelle
il y en a quand même une note ça peut
être ça peut être le grand foutoir ça
peut être un pays ingouvernable c'est
tout à fait possible mais la bonne
nouvelle c'est que le parlement on ne
pourra plus le mépriser que l'assemblée
elle va avoir un poids déterminant alors
avec des gens entre nu prn qui auront
peut-être pas beaucoup envie de négocier
discuter les textes et de faire du
compromis
mais quand même dans les nues paix si un
certain nombre de socialistes
écologistes de gens qui étaient des
membres de partis de gouvernement
il ya les l air il ya matière à trouver
des compromis et à inventer quelque
chose à trouver ce guy carcassonne
j'avais eu le très bon papier à ce sujet
là du figaro magazine sur sur cette
époque oui il va falloir inventer
quelque chose et il faudra peut-être le
faire avec un nouveau président de
l'assemblée nationale et se confirme que
richard ferrand est battu alors vous
avez d'ailleurs les premiers résultats
qui apparaissent grâce à un travail
remarquable de jean-pierre vanhelder
directeur technique des nouveaux médias
du figaro avec on le voit donc l'aider à
lui au premier tour mais comme on le
disait yves carl sans doute des
surprises à attendre côté richard
ferrand côté christophe castaner je peux
attaquer seul castaner
serez billy de montchanin
il y en a beaucoup qui vont
effectivement faire les frais de cette
j'ai l'impression d'après les
informations que eric woerth sauve de
justesse son siège mais c'est sûr que le
président de la république aussi sénat
où il va être d'une certaine façon dans
une situation beaucoup moins confortable
que précédemment c'est que les têtes
d'affiché ceux qui le soutenaient autour
de lui et bien
ne pourront plus le soutenir font
rappeler que françois bayrou n'est pas à
l'assemblée nationale qu' edouard
philippe n'est pas à l'assemblée
nationale et si ferrand est battu et
bien c'est encore un poids lourd qui ce
qui va disparaître si castaner est battu
et bien castaner qui est quand même le
chef de file du groupe se sera pas là
donc il va y avoir pour lui ça va être
compliqué il va falloir qu'il trouve de
nouveau de nouveaux piliers je regarde
les résultats qui tombent là que qu'on a
juste en dessous nous qui tombe sur le
bandeau du figaro
karl est égal on lisait tout à l'heure
là j'ai un devoir de résultat dans le
lot-et-garonne et ses députés et rennes
qui sont élus ce qui est là aussi
historique réalisé tout à leur opposer
et non mais absolument escudier tout à
l'heure mais avec les poussées du r'n
dans ces territoires dans ces terres de
conquête de l'ouest nerfs au sens large
en normandie aussi on a on a on a un
parti qui historiquement était plutôt
habitué à la la la à la façade est hélas
ils gagnent ils gagnent du terrain et
forcément en ayant 80 à 90 députés ça
veut dire que dans tout un tas de
circonscriptions où on n'imaginait pas
le rn l'emporter il a fini par
l'emporter alors totalement parce que
j'avais fait ce calcul pour le coup
c'est deux mémoires mais sur lot et
garonne il était arrivé de mémoire en
tête au premier tour mais la logique
aurait voulu que l'addition des suivants
l'empêchent d'accéder au second tour
c'est ce qui se passait généralement on
l'évoquait tout à l'heure ce mode de
scrutin implique qu'un parti qui est
isolé qui n'a pas de d'alliance
électorale ne peut pas gagner ne peut
pas bien sûr avoir la majorité là ce qui
est impressionnant c'est que les gens ne
respectent plus les consignes de vote on
le savait depuis longtemps mais là ça
s'est confirmé et 2 le rassemblement
national a totalement fait exploser
cette espèce de ceinture qui est de
sécurité qu'il y avait autour de lui qui
l'empêché d'avoir des électeurs en plus
de ces de ses sympathisants et de ce qui
venait dès le premier tour là il faudra
regarder attentivement circonscription
par circonscription mais s'il l'est pas
c'est dans le lot-et-garonne sur ces
deux circonscriptions ça veut vraiment
dire qu'il a augmenté le nombre de ses
électeurs de 30% au premier tour ils
arrivent à gagner voilà ce qui a été
qualifié avant parce que ça signifie
uniquement que les autres partis sont
les électeurs qui ont voté pour les
autres partis au premier tour on dit je
reste à la maison on peut se reporter
tout autant sur le rn que sur son
adversaire donc c'est ce concepteur sur
le front républicain il a complètement
disparu alors ça il sait sur le chat du
figaro live sur youtube nous dit c'est
quand les vrais résultats et ben pour
l'instant ce sont des premières
estimations on aura les résultats
définitifs évidemment demain matin mais
tout au long de la soirée tous les
résultats que vous voyez défiler juste
en dessous sur le bandeau ce sont les
résultats définitifs officiels du
ministère de l'intérieur et on va vous
remonterez tout de suite la projection
que nous avons eues à 20h par l'institut
ifop donc je vous le rappelle c'est la
majorité
présidentielle qui arrive en tête mais
bien en deçà des projections avec 210 à
250 députés dans la prochaine assemblée
nationale suivie de la nuque baisse avec
150 à 180 députés et la grosse surprise
elle vient du rn 80 à 100 députés donc
pour le rassemblement national le parti
de marine le pen qui du coup se
retrouverait avec un groupe à
l'assemblée nationale est d'ailleurs 44
avec un groupe qui passait un certain
nombre on a même des moyens plus
importants ce ca pour le à l'assemblée
vous avez vous pouvez réclamer pour le
coup on en parlait tout à l'heure la
présidente du groupe d'opposition
seraient encore
premier rôle d'opposition savons bien
réclamé par l'opposition mais ils
peuvent leur examen alors vu la
configuration de l'assemblée ça va être
difficile parce que on voit bien que les
autres ne voteront pas pour un candidat
du fn mais
ça m'étonnerait qu'ils ne réclameront
pas ce sens ce que
légitimement il pourrait ensuite il ya
la questure c'est à dire vraiment ce qui
concerne l'organisation de l'assemblée
il ya la vice-présidence aussi il ya des
vice présidences qui vont arriver
techniquement ils vont avoir droit des
vice-présidents jordan bardella donc
président du rassemblement national qui
s'est félicité d'un tsunami est reine je
cite je veux dire un immense merci aux
français qui se sont mobilisés et qui
ont permis une vague bleue marine on
commence le travail dès demain le
président est minoritaire et c'est son
mépris et son impuissance qui l'a fait
président minoritaire est ce que c'est
vrai est ce qu'il ya eu un regain de
mobilisation vous pensez en faveur du
hérel ou comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure c'est juste que certains ne se
sont pas déplacés et qui on regarde la
sueur sur les écrans l'ensemble des
scores des circonscriptions dans les
dents des scores des différents des
différents partis dans les différentes
circonscriptions
probablement que non probablement que
vous avez pu avoir ici ou là un petit
surcroît de mobilisation et rennes ubs
mais ce qui a joué surtout très
vraisemblablement c'est le refus
d'arbitré contre le fn dans la
circonscription le rn étaient présents
d'abstention qu'il était favorable aux
arènes quand vous regardez le
lot-et-garonne par exemple où vous avez
des candidats et rennes qui faisait à
peu près le même score que leur
adversaire au second tour pour que le rn
passe ça signifie que les électorats qui
avaient voté pour ensemble qui avaient
voté pour l air et bien ne se sont pas
plus reporté contre le rn que pour lui
certains beaucoup se sont abstenus mais
ce qu'ils ont fait un choix ont
probablement davantage aux trn encore
que contre les arènes donc plus de front
républicain une mobilisation accrue et
une représentation à l'assemblée
nationale qui ressemble un peu plus au
pays au pays réel que ce que l'on
pouvait avoir jusqu'à présent et
quelques un phénomène qui a été décrit
par jérôme fourquet part
dans un grand interview dans un grand
papier qu'il a fait pour le figaro où il
expliquait quand même comment
subrepticement depuis 2002 finalement ce
qui semblait être un plafond de verre
c'est quand même pas mal fissurer malgré
la défaite la cinglante défaite de
marine le pen au deuxième tour de
présidentielle oui bah le parti le
rassemblement national je dérive s'est
installé dans le pays disait le problème
du rassemblement national c'était un
problème de 2 le cadre en fait il
n'avait pas de représentant
qui
était qu avait une je dirais une ré
charisme suffisant une formation
suffisante un discours suffisamment
construit pour séduire les français y à
brouilla pendant longtemps n'y a eu que
jean marie le pen et quelques-uns et
marine le pen et quelques-uns mais là
maintenant bien ils ont d'abord ils ont
recentré leur discours en discours est
beaucoup moins agressive beaucoup un
brutal le ton a changé donc ils ont
réussi à trouver peut-être des cadres
qui est qu'ils adoptent ce discours là
qui sont en capacité de de relier le
discours de marine le pen même si sur le
fond quand vous regardez bien ce
discours qui reste quand même
extrêmement clivant maria puis les
références
de jadis à la colonisation à
l'antisémitisme à tout ça c'est quand
même un discours qui si vous le mettez
au pouvoir
je te pas cher de l'avenir de notre pays
alors 3,3 résultats qui viennent de
tomber de personnalité qu'on suivait
donc le ministre olivier dussopt qui est
élu député avec 58 points 74 % des voix
dernier abad également qui a été réélu
député dans la 5e circonscription de
l'ain avec
57,86 % des voix en revanche une autre
personnalité politique figure de la
république en marche christophe castaner
on en parle et qui est battue donc dans
les alpes de haute provence il obtient
48 51 % des voix et c'est donc le
candidat de l'ani paissent les ovales
terre qui est député dans sa
circonscription se constitueraient que
le rassemblement national à plus de
sièges que le que la france à soubise
alors ça c'est ce serait l'autre
information et d'autres surprises de
l'esc de la soirée à
jeudi semblerait à observer on va vous
restez avec nous pour continuer à suivre
ça ce qui est étonnant ont regardé tout
à l'heure dans une cirque dans la
première circonscription de charente une
députée
rassemblement national qui a été qui a
été élu dans une circonscription
d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant c'est
à vérifier mais qui je crois était très
disputée également par par la nuque donc
il ya quand même ce match du black du
bloc populaire
où on disait qu'il y avait un avantage à
priori à la nuit puis à la france
insoumise mais qui dans une france
périphérique qui peuvent être favorable
au rassemblement national oui c'est ce
qu'en disait tout à l'heure le front
républicain ne marche plus alors qu'est
ce qui ne marche plus parce que leur
assemblée nationale a réussi à desserrer
l'étau ou est ce qui ne marche plus
parce que c'était la nuit et donc le la
france insoumise et que les gens se
disaient entre la peste le choléra
finalement je m'abstiens je les laisse
se débrouiller et donc c'est celui qui
est arrivé en tête garde son avance et
qui se fait élire au second tour mais ça
ça ensemble aussi ils en ont gagné un
certain nombre donc ce n'est pas que ça
mais c'est vrai que ça
marius dans le chat qui nous qui me
sollicitent qui me demande madame
d'audrey et dénoue dans notre réflexion
c'est vrai que ça débat beaucoup sur le
chat du youtube figaro live j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir contribuer à votre
débat en tout cas se place s est élevée
nous dit rn premier parti de france sans
alliance est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce commentaire il faut modérer
quand même parce que vous avez
renaissance faut voir c'est le parti du
président outre l'essence qui est à
l'intérieur d'ensemble et renaissance
c'est l'ancienne république en marche il
faut voir combien il faut faire plus non
ça sera près d'une trentaine de
différence quand même mais c'est
intéressant de voir qu effectivement le
rassemblement national bat peut-être et
devant la france a soumis ça c'est
intéressant charles
vous salue en disant bravo très armés on
dit bravo mais également
sa donc entre 210 et 250 députés pour la
coalition ensemble c'est ce que vous
venez de voir 150 à 180 pour la nuque 60
à 70 pour lr udi et 80 à 100 députés
pour le rassemblement national c'est la
projection alors tout à l'heure ils le
disent et c'est ce qu'on va suivre
peut-être que le rassemblement national
obtiendrait ce qui serait également une
surprise plus de députés que la france
insoumise et damien abad qui est lui
réélu dans le noir est en revanche
brigitte bourguignon qui est battu
ministre de
lourds enjeux pour la réforme de la
santé est peut-être également toujours
des questions de vaccination etc parce
que c'était avec une des questions dans
les outre-mer dresser un énorme enjeu et
c'est un ministère très important et
donc c'est une ministre majeur qui est
éliminé on parlait de d'elisabeth bornes
si le résultat
eh bien celui annoncé à 52,48 en gros
c'est extrêmement serré quand même pour
la première ministre de se retrouver
gagnante seulement 2 avec avec deux
points d'avance on a évoqué tous les
autres noms de ceux qui ont été battus
je ne sais pas encore pour 1 million
charge pas si vous l'avez évoqué mais ce
sera ce sera un enjeu
ça veut dire que le roman de bureau
s'est enflammé ce sera l'enjeu sera de
ce sera un enjeu important que de
remanier fortement d'abord parce qu'on
humilie sera obligé puisque l'église
pourrait pas pour remettre en place tous
ceux qui sont au tapis fait un trouver
de nouveaux de nouveaux ministres pour
occuper ces marocains mais de toute
façon aussi pour montrer que le
président a tenu compte du message des
électeurs en tout cas de ceux qui sont
allés voter donc abad du soft
conserverait a priori leur poste tout
comme gérald darmanin qui annonce sa
victoire sur les réseaux sociaux
il annonce donc 57 52% des voix en sa
faveur en revanche donc on vient de le
dire brigitte bourguignon qui devrait
quitter son poste est-ce qu'on peut
rappeler à peu près combien de ministres
étaient en lice déjà 14 ans une
quinzaine d'autres étaient candidats et
c'est sûr qu'il va y avoir de la casse
parce qu'on sait déjà que la ministre
déléguée aux dom tom elle était déléguée
je crois aux dom tom mais les débats qu
on sait maintenant que ça commence à ce
matin puisque on a appris que justin
bien qu'ils aient
jamais
excusé
donc il va y en avoir d'autres c'est sûr
c'est sûr en revanche on sait que ce qui
avait été présenté comme une prise de
guerre
damien abad et bien terminée un bad
apparemment dans l'un il serait réélu
confortablement et clémentine autain par
l'instant d'une percée incroyable de la
gauche on peut on parler de ça bah oui
on peut parler de ça le diminue la chose
c'est que c'était assez attendu depuis
un moment et notamment depuis les
résultats du premier tour mais quand on
regarde je vois plus la dernière
projection mais on n'est pas loin on
n'est pas loin d'une centaine de députés
de plus que le total des voix de gauche
c'est quand même le premier pas le
premier enseignement c'est le pue le
très faible score de la majorité
présidentielle
le deuxième enseignement c'est la forte
poussée de la gauche mais ça n'est pas
une surprise et le troisième
enseignement on en a parlé à un bon
moment ensemble depuis tout à l'heure ça
c'est une surprise c'est la poussée du
rassemblement national
encore une fois on était au maximum à un
peu moins d'une cinquantaine de députés
dans les projections d'entre deux tours
il pourrait faire quasiment deux fois
mieux et c'est même déjà une
cinquantaine c'était une performance
inédite
puisqu'il avait fallu l'aide de françois
mitterrand avec la mise en place du
du
personnel pour permettre une entrée
d'une trentaine de députés à l'assemblée
à l'époque de jean marie le pen la halle
safire risque de faire trois fois mieux
yves claudius nous dit macron pour faire
passer ses réformes macro et mal ces
réformes libérales macro est mal parti
oui comme on devrait on sait pas trop
quelles sont les réformes qui voulait
engager à part les retraites et encore
vous pouvez passer du médiatique pour le
reste j'ai bien malin qui peut dire de
ce qu'il veut faire il veut apparemment
ils voulaient aussi b sainte est
confortée à le faire me gouverner en
faisant de la démocratie participative
en tirant les citoyens au sort avec le
conseil national de la refondation tout
ça c'est un c'est un vaste un vaste
maelström et on a bien du mal à s'y
retrouver je suis bien incapable de vous
dire quelles sont les réformes odeur de
sainteté retraite qui sont effectivement
à prévoir qu'est ce que vous allez y
était 1 qu'est ce que je vais des
territoires ce soit le la position du
rassemblement national enfin le le
résultat définitif du rassemblement
national ça me paraît très important car
au sein de la nuque comment ça va se
répartir parce qu'effectivement ils ont
augmenté en dz une centaine de députés
sauf qu'apparemment le parti socialiste
n'en bénéficie pas au mieux il a le même
nombre de députés que la dernière j cela
tire et au pire il en a moins autant
dire que la stratégie 25 députés alors
de
servir la stratégie de l'effort et pas
forcément la bonne il a été la réunion
comme l'a été largement réélu néanmoins
d'enseignement c'est peut-être du coup
on comprend mieux les stratégies mais si
la stratégie consiste à juste se faire
élire et éviter les autres le soient
c'est un peu difficile non mais voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est à dire qu' il
faudrait pas non plus quel est le
maquereau considère que parce qu'il ya
une centaine de députés
deux nuls en plus la france est à gauche
je ne suis pas sûr que c'est ce que ce
les français aient voulu dire
mais ça va être intéressant de voir les
conclusions qu'ils en tirent sachant
qu'après chaque élection généralement
ils tirent des conclusions différentes
des conclusions qui l'avait tirée de la
fois précédente c'est son fameux en même
temps mais et du coup ça te donne des
coups de barre à droite des coups de
barre à gauche qui sont compliquées là
on va voir sur quel à quel endroit il va
donner son coup de barre merci car mais
lui c'est merci frère merci vous on vous
quittez on rejoindra d'autres personnes
tout de suite un nouveau enfin une info
un poids lourd encore de la majorité qui
vient de tomber donc richard ferrand qui
avoue avoir été battu dans la sixième
circonscription du finistère avec 49
points 33% des voix tous les trains
rapides commentaires sur ça parce que
richard ferrand battu à brest j'ai
combattu en breton il y avait trois
poids lourds autour du président de la
république il a pu persuader l'assemblée
nationale dit richard ferrand ni bayrou
n'est pas débutée philippe n'est pas
député donc ça fait trop grande terre
est ce que richard ferrand déjà en 2000
seuls étaient présents étaient très
proches de d'emmanuel macron il avait
accentué cette proximité vraiment
emmanuel macron l'écouté et là c'est le
président de l'assemblée nationale
dire que tout avait été fait d'ailleurs
pour lui ouvrir une voie tranquille
parce qu'on sait qu'au sein de la
majorité d'autres espéraient et
notamment
une femme pouvoir être enfin une
première femme présidente de l'assemblée
nationale là il ya un grand vide il faut
même république s'il ya beaucoup de
présidents de l'assemblée nationale il
semblait tu sors ton qui se
représentaient qui ont été battus
pourrait voir sa merci à tous les deux
et on va tout de suite retrouvé timothée
d'hellemmes pour le point info mais vous
l'avez dit brunet vincent grosse défaite
pour le président de l'assemblée
nationale richard ferrand selon les
premières estimations de l'ifop il
arriverait en deuxième position dans la
sixième circonscription du finistère
avec 49 points 33% des voix face à la
candidate de la nuque s mélanie tome 1
vous l'avez dit donc pas de majorité
absolue pour emmanuel macron d'après
donc les premières estimations de l'ifop
le groupe ensemble remporterait ce soir
210 à 250 sièges de députés c'est loin
des 289 nécessaires pour remporter la
majorité absolue derrière ensemble sans
surprise sans surprise pardon viennent
les candidats de la nuque s avec 150 à
180 élus grosse percée pour le
rassemblement national qui disposerait
de 80 à 100 sièges le parti de marine le
pen qui serait donc en mesure de former
un groupe à l'assemblée nationale pour
la première fois de son histoire
m kühl en revanche pour les républicains
avec 60 à 70 sièges c'est beaucoup moins
que les 100 un élu de
2017 les résultats circonscription par
circonscription continuent de nous
parvenir au compte gouttes tout au long
de la soirée je rappelle que 15
ministres en exercice et jouent leur
avenir au gouvernement ce soir toujours
d'après l'ifop la première d'entre eux
et les avaient deux bornes serait élu ça
c'est dans la sixième circonscription du
calvados avec 52,3 pour cent des voix
elle était opposé au candidat de l'ani
baisse à noé gauchard ça passe également
pour le ministre du travail olivier
dussopt qu'il l'emporterait avec
58,74 % des voix dans la 2e
circonscription de l'ardèche et puis
d'après des résultats partiels du
ministère de l'intérieur cette fois ci
sachez que damien abad le nouveau
ministre des solidarités recueil à ce
stade 57,4 1 6% des voix dans la 5e
circonscription de l'un face à la
candidate du ps florence pisani et puis
on l'a dit à ce stade deux grands battus
du côté de la majorité présidentielle on
a parlé de richard ferrand le président
de l'assemblée nationale christophe
castaner également le patron des députés
de la république en marche qui serait
battue dans la deuxième circonscription
des alpes de haute provence avec 48 20
51% des voix il était face au candidat
de l'ani baisse léo walt
voilà on laisse véronique reichelt
rentrée thor le
nom avec triomphalement c'est vraiment
vous retrouve dans une heure pour les
nouveaux points infos et nous on démarre
une nouvelle tranche de décryptage et de
commentaires de ce second tour des
élections législatives avec un nouveau
plateau bonsoir emmanuel rivière
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
directeur des études politiques
internationales chez kantar
est avec nous également car nous venait
de tirer d'acteurs en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire
comment meurt les politiques c'est bon
comment sont morts les politiques
d'achat toiture lui définit non mais
enfin on rappellera quand vous êtes d'où
vous êtes venus le présenter en plateau
ici c'est passionnant et 7 aux éditions
du surf et et véronique raïs août qui
nous a rejoint donc en cours de toi info
comme vous avez pu le voir sur ces
images de bakbone consulting alors
peut-être un premier commentaire pour
vous véronique hoareau aux dames qu'avez
vous pensé de cette fois en tout cas qu
est ce qui ressort des réseaux sociaux
est ce qu'il ya plus d'intérêt que pour
le premier tour des législatives alors
oui il ya plus intéressant ça fait
parler ça fait beaucoup plus parler et
surtout ce qui fait beaucoup plus parler
c'est le score du rassemblement national
c'est essentiellement ça le fond des
discussions bien sûr beaucoup de
messages de ceux qui ont gagné qui très
content d'avoir gagné
normal mais c'est le score du
rassemblement national qui est laisse
pantois un grand nombre de de
commentaires d'internautes sachant qu'on
avait quand même observer mais loin
d'imaginer que ce serait ce score là que
effectivement les gens avaient l'air de
un peu plus assumer des choix rn pas
parce qu'ils étaient d'accord avec
rennes mais en disant on veut pas voter
pour ensemble donc ans et ensemble les
règles et beaucoup de gens de droite et
en particulier des sympathisants et
leurs examens moi je préfère est raide
ce qui était assez étonnant parce que
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on lit
habituel non non la deûle à avoir
imaginé qu'ils réussissent par la non
d'où le fait qu'il y ait autant de
commentaires ce soit sur ce sujet le
score du à rennes aussi c'est aussi vous
ce que vous soulignez ce soir en premier
en première conclusion emmanuel rivière
c'est un point extrêmement important
parce que le fait grâce au mouvement
national réussissent à convertir pas
loin de la moitié de ses candidats au
second tour en futur débuter est tout à
fait inédit si on monte deux élections
en arrière dans l'entre-deux tours des
élections de 2012 on était dans ces
psychodrames là où il y avait des
triangulaires est-ce qu'il fallait
retrait par très tu te retires pas tu
n'es pas un bon républicain et c'est au
final deux élus
qui étaient marion maréchal-le pen et
j'adore corps et gilbert collard voilà
on ne serait 80 90 il ya un sujet qui
est d'ailleurs un peu
certains c'est combien par rapport aux
autres groupes potentiellement présents
à l'assemblée nationale quand notamment
la nuit va se subdiviser donc c'est un
point particulier il demandera à être
analysées sans doute circonscription par
circonscription pour savoir où cela
s'est produit où s'est produit le
phénomène où finalement le
set ce plafond qui empêchait qu'à une
élection où il fallait faire plus de 50%
le rassemblement national connaissent de
grands succès a volé en éclats et les
gens pour lequel il la faire mon avis
sera en partie donné quand on regarde
pas dans quelle circonscription
précisément et face à qui ça s'est
produit après il ya pardon non si l'on
prend un peu de recul
il ya deux manières de lire ce le score
de ce soir si on est dans la séquence
habituel ellis et yves qui suivait une
présidentielle on est totalement clair
inconnu on est quand quelque chose
d'absolument stupéfiants est totalement
inédit si on regarde les choses
autrement et peut-être d'ailleurs comme
ça se passe ailleurs on a un président
de la république qui est au pouvoir
depuis depuis cinq ans et qui
confrontait une sorte d' élections
intermédiaires
emmanuel macron il a tout perdu depuis
2010 cette part évidemment les
législatives de 2017 et la
présidentielle toutes les autres il a
perdu les européennes 2019 il est
devancé par leurs semblables nationale
donc si on enlève la présidentielle en
fait on est dans un scénario assez
classique d'un pouvoir confronter à son
usure qui
demande en français lui redonner à une
majorité n'obtient une majorité cassé
étriqué et c'est tout se passe comme si
en fait la présidentielle n'avait pas eu
lieu elle a été juste elle l'élection de
confirmation l'élection anecdotique et
où finalement il ya une logique à
l'oeuvre au moment des initiatives qui
aident joue le sanctionner en partie au
gouvernement en place une première
annonce à une première réaction de
julien bayou mais on l'écoutera
peut-être en rediffusant c est ce que
c'est votre analyse
arnaud est d'abord quel est votre qu'est
ce que vous retenez de cette élection
observateur de la vie parlementaire que
vous avez à écouter c'est une situation
totalement inédite sous la vème
république clairement c'est la première
fois qu'un président de la république ne
dispose pas d'une majorité et on peut
même considérer que sa majorité relative
est un concept très relatif ce soir
parce que la même panne majoritaire à la
douma c'est à dire que la réalité c'est
que non seulement il n'obtient pas une
majorité relative avec les forces qui
sont constitutifs de la majorité mais
que si l'on regarde on verra en fonction
des évolutions ce soir mais même s'il y
avait un accord avec les l'air puisque
c'est peut-être l'hypothèse la plus
probable c'est une majorité relative
n'est même pas sûr que cette majorité
absolue n'est même pas assuré une
majorité absolue avec la bière n'est
même pas assurée donc on est dans un
dans un jet à dire dans une situation
qui sur le plan institutionnel est tout
à fait exceptionnel sous la vème
république avec un président qui a été
confirmé il y a de cela deux mois et qui
se trouve aujourd'hui quasiment empêcher
sur le plan du fonctionnement
parlementaire ce qui d'ailleurs va poser
aussi le problème du maintien de son
premier ministre quand même d'une
certaine manière parce que c'était elle
qui conduisait la majorité elle est élue
à 52 ou 53 % dans sa circonscription et
le moins qu'on puisse dire on peut pas
considérer que le résultat aujourd'hui
de la majorité est à la hauteur de ce
que pouvait éventuellement attendre
emmanuel macron même si c'est emmanuel
macron qui est récemment le comptable
exclusif de cette situation ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point
c'est en effet le score du rassemblement
national mais moi je partage qui
viennent des dix lots secours du
rassemblement national le score grâce
aux mesures le score du rassemblement
national il est conforme au poids
politique de ce que constitue le
rassemblement national dans la vie
politique française maintenant depuis
plusieurs élections comment voulez-vous
que une candidate qui atteint 42% au
soir du second tour de l'élection
présidentielle ne dispose pas ce n'était
pas le cas jusqu'à maintenant d'un
groupe parlementaire à la hauteur de
cette réalité politique il ya quelque
chose qui s'est passé ce soir il faudra
regarder circonscription par
circonscription où la porosité s'est
établie on voit qu'il ya peut-être eu un
aussi un certain nombre d'électeurs dans
un certain nombre de circonscriptions
quand il y avait des affrontements entre
un candidat de la majorité un candidat
est reine des électeurs de gauche pour
pu peut-être procéder au vote
révolutionnaire
ce qu'on appelait le vote
révolutionnaire donc il ya quelque chose
qui s'est passé là ce soir troisième
point toujours concernant leur assemblée
nationale il faudra bien regarder la
répartition des groupes c'est à dire que
il y à une bataille ce soir qui se joue
entre
la france insoumise et le rassemblement
national pour savoir quel sera le
premier groupe parlementaire et cette
question est absolument essentiel
puisque vous savez très bien que en
principe la commission des finances
est échu au groupe parlementaire
dominant donc il ya là quelque chose
aussi de position par dans le groupe
parlementaire de position dominante donc
là aussi il ya une question sur le fond
on est dans une situation pour terminer
qui rend
assez peu gouvernable pour l'instant il
faut être clair le pays qui nous ramène
à une situation que j'allais dire en
fait ce qui est intéressant sur le plan
historique c'est que c'est la quatrième
république sous la vème république ce
soir marine le pen est en train
d'arriver sur scène à hénin-beaumont en
écoute et on suit
[Applaudissements]
ouais
mesdames messieurs
chers amis
au terme de cette longue séquence
électorale de mise en place des
institutions pour le quinquennat qui
vient le peuple s'est exprimé
surmontant l'obstacle d'un mode de
scrutin particulièrement injuste et
inadapté aux valeurs de notre temps il a
décidé d'envoyer un très puissant groupe
parlementaire de députés rassemblement
national à l'assemblée
qui devient ainsi un peu plus nationale
ce groupe sera de très loin le plus
nombreux de l'histoire de notre famille
politique
j'adresse toute ma gratitude aux
électeurs qui leur ont témoigné leur
confiance
cette confiance nous oblige nous avons
atteint les 3 objectifs que nous nous
étions fixés
faire des manuels macro un président
minoritaire de manière à préserver le
pays du règne d'un parti unique et d'un
président sans contrôle dans l'exercice
du pouvoir avec le risque que nous lui
connaissons d'en abuser pour suivre la
recomposition politique indispensable au
ressourcement démocratique et au seuil
du troisième millénaire pris en otage
par le mondialisme assumer le triomphe
de l' idée salvatrice de nation enfin de
constituer un groupe d'opposition
déterminant face aux des constructeurs
d'en haut les maquereaux nist et au des
constructeurs d'en bas
cette extrême gauche anti républicaine
nous incarnerons une opposition ferme
c'est à dire sans connivence mais une
opposition responsable
c'est à dire respectueuse des
institutions est toujours constructif
parce que notre seul et unique
seule l intérêt de la france et du
peuple français
[Applaudissements]
ce nouveau groupe parlementaire national
et républicain aura à coeur dans
l'esprit de rassemblement national que
nous portons d'associer tous les élus et
mouvements politiques qui souhaitent
avec nous participer au redressement du
pays avec ses dizaines et ses dizaines
de députés de coeur et de conviction du
rassemblement national qui sont d'abord
des citoyens français soucieux du bien
public vous aurez la certitude de voir
défendu au parlement vos idées sur
l'immigration la sécurité le chômage la
justice fiscale et sociale
les territoires oubliés les citoyens
maltraités ou la démocratie bafouée
[Applaudissements]
les nouveaux visages
les nouveaux visages que vous allez
découvrir des visages rayonnants
d'enthousiasmé de vie sont l'avant-garde
de cette nouvelle élite politique qui
prendra la responsabilité du pays
lorsque l' aventure macro aura pris fin
au delà du groupe parlementaire nous
allons poursuivre le travail de
rassemblement des français ou sans un
grand mouvement populaire unifiant tous
les patriotes de droite et de gauche un
rassemblement national pour défendre le
pays face à un effondrement que nous
constatons chaque jour
et quand les français le déciderons
d'engager le redressement dont la france
a urgemment besoin j'appelle tous les
français d'où qu'ils viennent quelle que
soit leur origine quelle que soit leur
situation personnelle ou professionnelle
à nous rejoindre dans cette aventure
prat ternel et exaltante qui s'appelle
la france notre seule ambition est de
servir les français nous nous battons
pour eux pour nos enfants pour le pays
vive la république vive la france
on
va
vous venez d'entendre marine le pen donc
il a été élu député dans sa
circonscription du pas de calais et en
même temps j'entends a démarré son
discours on va tout de suite écouter
peut-être la fin de son discours et on
reprendra l'intégralité ensuite
sans le son
d'ici là nul ce sens
nanterre
ouvriers et ouvrières
salariés de tous ordres de toutes les
régions de france
arrivant par dizaines sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale
le maquereau nîmes ne s'est pas
seulement mis en faillite lui même il a
plongé le pays dans une impasse et tout
à l'heure déjà nous avons entendu qu'il
s'agissait de dépasser les clivages
il n'y a aucun clivage a dépassé avec
nous parce que nous ne sommes pas du
même monde nous disons pas les mêmes
objectifs nous n'avons pas les mêmes
valeurs nous croyons pas même si dur
et comme nous pensons qu'ils le savent
alors nous en concluons qu'il se prépare
à d'autres entend peut-être toujours est
il que si nous sommes à la fin de la
soirée la nuque acquis par diverses
manoeuvres on a déjà commencé par
revenir et on a déjà commencer par
retirer quasiment 21 députés d outre-mer
et à commencer par hausse de l' union ou
si c'est un succès son camp a marqué
[Applaudissements]
non
je veux vous dire
que de toutes les mobilités son or noir
moi
je dors je pense à ceux de booba mais
mon engagement et de leur a jusqu'à mon
dernier souffle dans les premiers
dévorant
le renchérissement
[Applaudissements]
oui le grand jaillissement de l'histoire
du plus profond de ce qu'est la france
des rébellions et des révolutions oui ce
grand jaillissement dorénavant un visage
le visage de notre collectif celui de
l'union populaire
les déci les plus inouïes vont
s'accumuler devant vous que ce soit le
changement climatique que ce soit la
grande crise financière
par quelques côté que vous voyez ce
monde finissant
c'est à chaque fois des réponses
fulgurante qu'il faudra apporter pas un
instant nous ne renonçons à l'ambition
d'être ceux qui gouvernent ce pays et il
amène un autre horizon pas un instant
les salariés ne baisserons les bras face
à l'instant les jeunes ne se diront
fatigué de la ligue
ne doutez pas de vous même
ne cédez jamais à l'impatience
penser que chaque difficulté à deux
visages celui qui s'oppose à vous et
celui de l'opportunité qu'elle vous
propose
plus grands sont les bouleversements
plus grandes sont les opportunités
la france
est une nation politique quand bien même
elle s'abstient beaucoup et même quand
elle le dit par son abstention
ne méprisons jamais notre peuple
écoutons toujours avec attention tout ce
qui se dit car dans sa patience infinie
il a montré qu'il était capable de
trancher et de décider d'avancer et tel
est le mandat que vous avez ce soir
demain matin peut-être que vous vous
réveillerez avec une majorité de la nuit
par l'assemblée nationale
ou bien avec le premier groupe
aucun tripotage
aucun arrangement
non nous privera de cette possibilité et
si ça n'est pas le cas alors vous
regarderez d'abord la puissance
formidable que vous avez accumulé vive
la france vive la république
voilà donc jean luc mélenchon qui vient
de s'adresser depuis le siège de la
nuque avec d'autres élus de gauche on
voit que leur assigne un du parti
socialiste le parti socialiste qui
aurait d'ailleurs peut-être sensiblement
non seulement le même nombre voire moins
deux députés que lors de la précédente
la présente législature on va envahir
revenir d'avoir peut-être un premier
commentaire sur ce qu'on vient
d'entendre jean luc mélenchon arnaud
alors c'est à jean luc mélenchon qui
peut évidemment exciper malgré tout
d'avoir remis la gauche sur ses deux
jambes électorale et de gens qui sont
parfaitement dynamique ceci dit il ya
peut-être une petite déception ce soir
parce que le résultat n'est peut-être
pas à la hauteur de ce qu'il attendait
non seulement bien évidemment l'objectif
de cohabitation mais le fait que le
rassemblement national reviennent très
fort dans le jeu ce soir lui vole un peu
quand même la vedette sur le plan
médiatique ensuite il faudra mesurer le
rapport de forces est à dire il sera
très intéressant encore une fois de
regarder quel est le score du groupe du
futur groupe elle est fille parce que
est ce que ce sera le principal groupe
d'opposition au sein d'assemblées
nationales enola il ya encore une fois
une concurrence avec le rassemblement
national ce soit
ensuite bon on voit bien que ce discours
c'est un discours qui prépare d'ores et
déjà la suite c'est souvent le cas avec
jean luc mélenchon de toute façon il
prépare toujours la suite au soir des
résultats des élections là on voit bien
que il va y avoir le combat
parlementaire qui va être disons le
moteur principal de ce groupe ou dessins
certains groupes d'opposition que
constituera la nuque mais il ya aussi
vraisemblablement le combat social que
prépare là aussi comme il l'avait voulu
le faire en 2010 7 jean luc mélenchon
donc tout cela augure d'une situation
qui sera particulièrement tendue à la
fois sur le plan j'allais dire au social
et sur le plan parlementaire
alors que d'une interpelle en dix ans
vincent mélenchon a permis au ps de
sauver les meubles après leur score à la
présidentielle certes enfin il les
esprits il prévoyait un peu plus quand
même ne pouvait espérer conserver leur
groupe qu'ils étaient une trentaine de
députés là selon les projections et on
serait à moins alors à y voir les deux
lectures d'ailleurs au sein du parti
socialiste
certains diront mais si nous avions
couru sous nos propres couleurs compte
tenu de l'implantation au sortant etc on
aurait pu faire mieux que en
s'embarquant dans la nuque quand
d'autres essaieront de démontrer que
sans cela est bien le sort du parti
socialiste aurait été un peu à l'avenant
de ce que de ce qu'a été le sort de sa
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
mais par rapport à ce débat là il ya
bien d'autres je pense qu'un élément de
contexte qui est important alors je
crois pas trop spéculer en disant qu'on
est quand même dans un joyeux bazar que
personne n'avait préparé pire que eelv
et trois scénarios un majorité absolue
pour ensemble l'âge au rite est relative
et puis dans la tête de jean luc
mélenchon et de deux
certains soutiens peut-être une re
surprise mais une majorité si faible
pour la république en marche ça change
complètement la donne et je pense que
tout le monde est en train de découvrir
un peu ce qui est en train de se
produire on est juste moi je considère
je fais partie de ceux qui considèrent
qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de majorité
c'est à dire que si on reste dans un
état de situation qui est celui qui est
en train de se dégager ce soir ce
gouvernement et 10 ont
explosé à des motions de censure qui
peuvent d'un moment à l'autre le
renverser c'est à dire dans la logique
parlementaire la logique parlementaire
de la vème république c'est une logique
de majorité absolue clairement c'est
comme ça que le président de la
république et le président de gaulle
avait véritablement penser les
institutions on a vu que avec sous
rocard en 1988 en plus à une époque où
on pouvait utiliser le 49-3 de manière
totalement illimité donc c'était
beaucoup plus simple on a vu que ça a
été déjà compliqué mais là aujourd'hui
au regard du rapport de forces est à
dire avec un champ politique qui
complètement éclatée qui est totalement
atomisé où on ne voit plus les lignes de
force qui peuvent un moment donné
dégager une majorité aujourd'hui ce soit
emmanuel macron tels que ça se profile
est un président de la république qui
n'a pas de majorité on va y revenir
julien maio est en train de prendre la
parole en l'écoutant c'est en faisant
nous et nous le revendiquons oui ces
opposants évidemment et la menace pour
l'ex pour la république qui représente
extrême droite et les rebelles lrm a mis
un signe égal entre nous les
progressistes les humanistes les
écologistes et socialistes les
communistes les insoumis et les
adversaires de la république c'est
extrêmement grave ils ont voulu éviter
la défaite au prix du déshonneur et ce
soir on a ils ont et la défaite et le
déshonneur
n'oublions pas la république c'est nous
rendra plus le son
immense colère parce que ce qui se
présentait comme le barrage se sont
faits les marchepieds de l'entrée en
masse de l'extrême droite à l'assemblée
nationale qui nous faudra combattre
évidemment
fierté
fierté parce que vous voyez là encore
sur la tribune cette coalition cette
bannière commune nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale fierté
de pouvoir voir les socialistes
applaudissent ce soir applaudissez les
des communistes à petit ce soir
les écologistes s'il vous plaît applaudi
ce soir
et les insoumis
vous pouvez les applaudir parce que
c'est aussi les insoumis évidemment en
premier lieu qui ont rendu cette
coalition possible
ils m'inspirent t parce que nous avons
déjoué toutes les produits tous les
pronostics et que ce soir j'espère parce
que la nuit sera longue et que beaucoup
de sièges vont se jouer à quelques
dizaines de voix près ce soir nous
pouvons encore déjouer les projections
en sièges
fierté aussi si vous me permettez le
petit passage pour ce parti qui porte
une grande idée l'écologie parce que ce
soir nous pouvons nous pouvons espérer
envoyer le plus grand groupe de
l'histoire de l'écologie politique à
l'assemblée nationale renforcer les
rangs de la gauche rend penser les rangs
de la gauche est ensemble comptait 3 3
fois plus de députés que dans le mandat
précédent ça peut tout changer
évidemment sur la saisine du conseil
constitutionnel sur les motions de
censure sur l'émotion projet sur les
référendums d'initiative partagée
espoirs enfin et j'en termine parce que
ce que nous avons construit ne s'arrête
pas là ce que nous avons construit ça ne
s'arrête pas là nous allons travailler
ensemble à l'assemblée dans les
intergroupes et mieux encore nous avons
vu sur le terrain dans ses campagnes que
nous sommes capables de faire campagne
ensemble là où nous étions uniquement en
contre dans les manifestations nous
pouvons construire ensemble et ça ça me
remplit d'espoir merci encore bravo tout
le monde
l'entendre je vous qui s'est exprimé au
nom de la nuque baisse et on a une
nouvelle projection d'ailleurs de
l'assemblée nationale à vous montrer il
est 20 heures 58 et voici donc les
dernières estimations l'affinage selon
l'ifop donc c'est ensemble qu'ils
arrivent bien en tête avec 210 à 240
députés suivi de la nuit ps entre 170 et
180 15 55 à 65 députés donc pour elle
est rude et i et 80 à 95 pour le rn
avant de donner la parole à daphné
caravaca pour avoir les dernières
informations sur les élus et les battus
de ce 2e tour gaël
pour l'instant ça reste toujours le rn
qui est reste la surprise quand même
majeur de la soirée oui parce que
contrairement à ce que disait julien
bayou les hommes politiques aiment bien
dire déjouant tous les pronostics et ses
états mais en réalité le score de la
nuque baisse est assez conforme à ce
qu'on s'attendait depuis dimanche
dernier les surprises elles proviennent
d'abord peut-être dans l'ordre je sais
pas mais de d'ensemble qui chez un score
encore plus mauvais que le mauvais score
qui lui était prédit voyez on avait une
fourchette basse à la fourchette la plus
basse de notre sondage du moins milieu
de semaine était à 252 on serait encore
en dessous
et puis bien sûr la surprise positive
pour eux c'est le rn qui au mieux
pouvait espérer une cinquantaine de
sièges dans les diverses projections et
qui montera à plus de 80
vraisemblablement et je rejoins ce que
vous disiez on en parlait déjà sur le
premier plateau c'est
la grande incertitude dans la question
que je me pose là c'est ce que vous
disiez arnaud c est ce que il y aura une
majorité théorique c'est à dire est ce
que finalement ensemble associée aux
divers droite et à l air dépassera les
289 ce qui semble quand même probable
sur les projections qu'on voit là si on
raisonne en milieu de fourchette ça
semble probable et ça promet
effectivement d'être quelque chose
d'assez certains diront ingouvernable
mais compliquées ou à tout le moins pour
pouvoir gouverner avec sur les sa gauche
et sur sa droite des députés extrêmement
radicaux et qu'ils auront du mal à
trouver des compromis entre nu prn et ça
c'est un changement oui alors il faut
qu'elle signale une chose c'est que
cette hypothèse une majorité relative au
noir du majorité absolue avec les ailes
r c'était pas une hypothèse du tout qui
était prévu on pensait plutôt une
majorité relative ou une majorité
absolue dans le cadre de la majorité
actuelle de la majorité présidentielle
donc ça c'est un facteur nouveau et
nos projections de milieu de semaine on
était sûr justement une une fourchette
de 250 de à 204 attendez-vous à 0,42 à
62 mais ce qu'ils sont issus très
largement en réalité du score du premier
tour donc au premier tour on pouvait se
dire ça est ce qu'il aura la majorité
absolue pardon mais la question c'est
est-ce as qu'il parviendra à une
majorité absolue éventuellement avec
avec l ère où seuls ou ou pas
dans les projections oui c'était
envisageable mais pas dans l'ingéniérie
politique est ici qu'en sait c'est que
au niveau du groupe et l'air et au sein
des états majors et là il y aura des
divisions à doha qui seront bien
évidemment favorable éventuelle guerre à
un accord de gouvernement voit en tout
cas à gérer au cas par cas les
différents textes et puis on sait qu'il
ya quand même une aile de l air qui
reste totalement hostile à toute
négociation avec emmanuel macron et qui
eux ne voudra pas vraisemblablement
rentrer dans un bateau dont elle estime
qu'il est un bateau très incertaine
aujourd'hui il est 21h01 et daphné
caravaca est avec nous pour le dernier
enfin pas le dernier pardon son premier
pour info cette petite brune alors le
premier point à ne pas manquer à ce
stade de la soirée électorale c'est le
score historique du rassemblement
national qui a obtenu 10 fois plus de
députés qu'en 2017 vous en parliez
justement en plateau on en compterait
entre 80 et 95 pour le moment dont
marine le pen qui a été élu avec 62 %
des voix vous l'aurez compris pour
l'heure nous ne parlons que de
chiffres basés sur des estimations et
parmi les membres du gouvernement qui
ont été élus ce soir député de leur
circonscription mon compte damien abad
le ministre des solidarités des
solidarités pardon qui a été réélu dans
sa circonscription de l'ain avec 57% des
voix ce qui lui permet de conserver son
poste au gouvernement de la même manière
gérald darmanin se réjouit sur twitter
d'avoir été élu dans la sixième
circonscription de tourcoing avec 57%
lui aussi des voix et pour ne citer
qu'une victoire de plus c'est elisabeth
bornes la première ministre qui a été
élu début députés dans le calvados avec
52% des voix maintenant si on prend un
peu de recul sur les sièges l'assemblée
nationale la coalition ensemble ferait
donc face à une majorité relative bien
loin du franc succès de 2017 puisque
pour ce second tour des législatives la
majorité présidentielle obtiendrait pour
le moment encore une fois entre 210 et
240 sièges à l'assemblée nationale eric
dupond moretti a même qualifié les
résultats de décevant de la même manière
du côté des l air qui constituait la
principale force d'opposition avec 112
élus à l'assemblée aurait désormais
d'après les premiers chiffres parus
entre 55 et 65 sièges à l'assemblée et
on revient dans 30 minutes pour plus de
chiffres dans notre prochain point info
avec timothée d'élèves merci beaucoup
daphné peut-être une question un point
du tout repartons avec sur les réseaux
sociaux
qu'est ce qui se dit actuellement
véronique et s il ya un petit peu plus
d'ambiance que ce qu'on avait observé
jusqu'à présent je ne parle pas de
l'ambiance en plateau où j'ai résisté
ils essayent de phase 1b tableau c'est
la blague à l'imam s'est par contre est
stabilisé non et c'est ce que je disais
beaucoup beaucoup plus de réactions que
au premier tour donc ils continuent tous
à commenter le sujet de rassemblement
national et commentent aussi pas mal le
discours de jean luc mélenchon qui dit
que en gros s'il ya le rassemblement
national c'est pas de sa faute
en tout cas c'est comme ça qu'ils vont
interpréter et les agglos dit c'est à
peu plus compliqué que ça et c'est
peut-être justement qu'il n'a pas pu
empêcher ou séduire plus les électeurs
essentiellement voilà qu'il n'a pas
réussi à les convaincre de changer donc
il ya un débat qui est en train de
sanctions internationales aujourd'hui
seddiki comptable du résultat du
recensement national c'est le président
république parce que c'est le président
la république avait fait de son objectif
de recul du rassemblement national un
objectif depuis 2010 est indéniablement
aujourd'hui c'est un échec parce que
tout simplement on a une parlementaire
qui va être un loup parlementaire qui
arrive avec une dimension qui est
historique qu'on n'a jamais connu sous
la vème république mais c'est jusqu en
fait qu'on regarde ce qui se sont
comment se disent qu'en fait c'est quand
même normal que ce soit le premier parti
il s'est souvent des commentaires aux
besoins dans le fond c'est celui qui est
arrivé en face du président des
républicains lors de l'élection
présidentielle de qui se pose plus la
question de comment est-ce qu'on n'a pas
plus anticipé et quels sont les gens qui
finalement ont voté pour pour le
rassemblement national alors question
pour vous emmanuel pour google c'est que
du ch qui nous dit j'adore les
commentaires des sondeurs le soir des
résultats chaque fois le demandent que
les sondages ont tout faux
ce qui est vrai c'est que dans les
projections qui avait été fait jusqu'à
présent
on n'avait pas vu à rennes 6e et même
douchée nous puisqu'on l'avait annoncé
mme avec cinq sièges au départ et
c'était pas aucun de vos deux instituts
en cause mais
le
donc au cas et personne n'avait vu quand
même une dalle et prédit une république
une coalition de majorité présidentielle
aussi basse oui on va pas dire qu'on
avait vu quelque chose alors qu'on a
découvert avec des estimations qui
émanent par ailleurs aussi les sondeurs
1 l mais alors bon un point technique ce
qui permet de projeter les sièges à
l'assemblée nationale à partir de
sondages ce sont des projections à
partir de son âge à des sondages on se
bat dans les 577 circonscriptions pour
demander qui va être élu on est obligé
de faire des hypothèses à partir d'une
part des résultats de la présidentielle
d'autre part des résultats du premier
tour des législatives et d'hypothèses de
report et qui est un point clé à mon
avis et résultat d'aujourd'hui c'est que
son entrée en lice une population qui
celle qui donne le plus de fil à
retordre aux sondeurs ce sont les
abstentionnistes intermittents il faut
bien avoir en tête que un taux de
participation qui évoluent si peu entre
les deux tours
avec juste deux points en moins du
premier tour du second tour par rapport
au premier c'est beaucoup de gens qui
sortent parce qu'ils n'ont plus leur
candidat et qui lâche la sphère en cours
de route et beaucoup de gens qui ne vont
voter que pour le deuxième tour il y a
cinq ans et à peu près 5 millions de
personnes pour lâcher la fer entre les
deux tours est à peu près 3 millions un
peu moins de 3 millions qui sont rentrés
et évidemment vous imaginez bien que ces
individus là qui considère que c'est pas
si important que ça pour aller au
premier tour mais qui compte tenu du
contexte auriel uniquement pour le
second tour effectivement peuvent créer
des surprises tout cas sont plus
difficiles à cerner quand il s'agit de
projection comme celle que auquel les
sondeurs se sont livrés qui parfois se
joue à deux trois points près d'un an et
dans de nombreuses circonscriptions
alors sachant que quand même peut-être
on peut apporter un correctif je vous
donne la parole galles c'est que il y à
il ya des dynamiques qui sont en oeuvre
et ont même si on n'avait pas perçu un
résultat final comme celui-là dimanche
on voyait des dynamique cam se dessinait
entre les deux tours a quitté les
sondages qu'on a fait ensemble avec avec
trois coupables ici sur ce plateau le
figaro doxa en premier lieu et véronique
soul qui associe bonne balle jaune
consulter en fourchette basse
pour four quand même pas dire n'importe
quoi du ensemble a été donnée à 252 ok
donc ils feront un petit peu moins
encore cela donnait un fourchette basse
à 210 oui mais en fourchette haute ils
sont à 240 il se susurre certains je
crois même un peu au-delà la france et
aucun a priori
a priori ensemble fait bien un score
très mauvais et qui qui est c'était ce
qui était annoncé même si ça va au delà
nubes était donné à 179 entre 179 et 220
bons ils font à peu près le bas de la
fourchette me semble-t-il l air était
donné entre 42 et 62 dans notre dernier
sondage ils seront dans un étiage pas
très éloigné la surprise elle vient du
rnc ce qu'on s'est dit depuis le début
et là je rebondis sur ce que disait
emmanuelle et dont on a parlé lors du
premier plateau comment sont faits sont
faites sont effectués les projections
donc je reviendrai pas dessus on en a
parlé tout à l'heure et manuel l'a
rappelé ça signifie quoi ça signifie que
vous avez énormément de circonscriptions
dans l'est gagnable ou est reine on est
à peu près à 90 et là je parle même pas
de sondages quand on regardait les
scores de premier tour il y avait 90
circonscriptions gagnables peut-être 95
ça signifie qu'ils ont quasiment gagné
tout ce qu'il était possible de gagner
en hypothèses les plus favorables pour
eux et donc c'est bien sûr une surprise
et elle s'explique encore une fois on le
disait aussi tout à l'heure par des
éléments qu'on enregistre aussi dans les
enquêtes donc c'est pas complètement
inutiles qui montre qu'il n'y a plus de
front républicain et que on a testé dans
deux sondages pour le figaro tous les
trois en cours de semaine ce que ferait
les gens ce que souhaitait les gens en
cas de l'affrontement nuit passée rennes
ou ensemble et rennes que devait dire
les autres
la réponse c'est rien taisez-vous on ne
veut pas de consignes et quand on
regardait les préférences des électeurs
il n'y avait pas de front républicain
non plus parce qu'il ne glisse nous il
ne nous disait pas qu'ils voteraient
davantage contre le rn pour lui faire
barrage que pour celui ci donc il ya
bien un phénomène qui se passe cette
semaine qui est la confirmation d'une
tendance de fond qu'on avait déjà vu ce
qui est l'explosion complète de toute
notion front républicain pour confirmer
ce que légal pour pour avoir selon le
député ce soir il faut que le
rassemblement national est emporté dans
un nombre significatif de ces
transcriptions ou son score du premier
tour était autour de 30% ce qui ne
permettait dans le passé une victoire du
rassemblement national ou plutôt du
front national d'ailleurs que en cas de
triangulaire passer de 30% à 50% ce qui
le score nécessaire pour gagner annuel
illustre complètement ce que ce que dit
elle jusqu'à présent dans notre histoire
un score de 30% au premier tour pour le
rassemblement national opposé à un
candidat en duel c'était fini c'était
pas des vues pour le rassemblement
national
après sur la leçon il est lé
les analyses que tout faire du score de
enfin du résultat d'aujourd'hui est un
point qui est important de garder en
tête je pense que gaël confirmera
puisque c'est un quelque chose qui suit
des sondages lorsqu'on leur demandait
aux français leur scénario préféré il
disait ne pas vouloir que les mazel
matran avec une majorité absolue c'est
sévère mais ne pas vouloir non plus que
jean luc mélenchon est une majorité
absolue et donc ça
explique aussi c'est à dire qu'elle en
fait voilà après une certaine histoire
ils ont obtenu ce qu'il désirait
mais pour illustrer en chiffres c'est
exactement ça on avait une espérance sur
une majorité relative surtout pas
mélenchon premier ministre ou disette il
m'est encore moins emmanuel macron avec
une majorité absolue est d'habitude et
je pars donc pour l'interruption mais
d'habitude c'est pas parce qu'on veut
quelque chose à titre individuel que ça
se réalise dans les 577 nommé c'est
plutôt l'inversé un point explication
c'est ce qu'à un moment bon dans les
duels
nuque et l'hérault m ous quand on veut
une majorité relative c'est pas facile
qu'est ce qu'on fait de son bulletin
savoir qu'avec mairie de l'abstention
dans les données on y met à nu pas
l'erreur quel est le bulletin de vote
finalement incarne le mieux en nombre de
circonscriptions ni macro ni mélenchon à
un moment c'était le vote cet été le bus
un rassemblement national aussi mais
est-ce que c'est pas aussi en folie mais
le sens de l'histoire
arnaud bénédictine le sens de l'histoire
que nous vivons c'est à dire que depuis
2010 cette marine depuis le 2012 marine
le pen devant aujourd'hui que mélenchon
à chaque élection est depuis 2010 cette
marine le pen est au deuxième tour
la réalité c'est que s'ils voulaient
jean luc mélenchon par une communication
politique très habile avait réussi
finalement à nous expliquer que la
gauche était la principale force
d'opposition dans ce pays il avait créé
un formidable effet d'optique qui a eu
des effets électoraux quand même parce
qu'il faut être clair ce soir là
véritablement battue c'est un succès
aussi pour jean luc mélenchon et ce
n'est vraiment pas le succès qui
l'attendait et déjà dès le premier tour
on a fait la queue il y avait cet effet
d'optique avait assez bien fonctionné
parce qu'elle l'a poussée du
rassemblement national on la voit dedans
donc plusieurs circonscriptions avec en
plus une géographie électorale qui
s'étend c'est à dire que le rapport
national a toujours une géographie
électorale qui poussait lors de la
présidentielle mais qui refluaient dans
un certain nombre de zones lors des
législatives et là on voit moi ce qui me
frappe c'est qu'on voit des des coins où
le rassemblement national et peut-être
fort lors de la présidentielle mme fm
lors des législatives et qu'il advienne
fort au niveau d'el islah tive je pense
le sud-ouest dans le sud ouest c'est
très intéressant je regarde et ailleurs
le département du lot également tedder
vous avez deux députés sur trois dans
une terre qui est radical socialiste à
villeneuve sur lot de l'ancienne
circonscription que jérôme cahuzac pas
ce rassemblement national marmande qui
est la première circonscription à avoir
élu un député communiste en 1920 pas ce
rassemblement national en gironde vous
avez là aussi une candidat du
rassemblement national qui est élu donc
vous avez une extension de la géographie
électorale sur le plan territorial du
rassemblons la solaire ça veut dire que
le versement d'intérêts est en train de
réussir finalement ce qu'il n'avait
jamais réussi jusqu'à présent une
implantation locale qui bien évidemment
constituent de ce produit là un
phénomène aujourd'hui assez historique
sur le plan de son histoire
le succès
s'est d'ailleurs
l'effet d'optique a pas trente marcheurs
un jeu l'effet d'optique il a consisté à
convaincre les partenaires indiens il
nous faut un seul candidat sinon on va
vers des déperditions quand même il ya
un succès politique quand même c'est
qu'il ya pas de déperdition sur
l'agrégation
des différents courants ça en produits
normalement c'est faudra regarder je
pense que pas dégradation là où c'était
face à un ensemble non je parte sur le
premier tour la hauteur du projet autour
d'un débat nourri non ils ont fait alors
jean-luc mélenchon finalement ne
s'arrête pas de parler il est enserré
dans le qg de la nuque et d'après
laurent millet de la rue
cissé on se serre les coudes où chacun
pour soi on installe des tuyaux pour
amener de la flotte tout allait acheter
votre bouteille d'eau d'accord donc les
deux grands principes qui organisent la
pensée politique de ce pays où la grande
révolution de 1789 qui sont en mouvement
ils sont là qu'il les prend en charge
qui va le faire alors normalement biais
des institutions il ya tout un appareil
qui est destiné à vous faire fermer
votre boucher il somptueux naples en ce
moment on a eu à peu près trois semaines
d'âge urnes en stock j'ai lu des textes
fantastique une page entière qui doit y
avoir 400 lignes 500 de bernard henri
lévy
attendait et c'est du travail quand même
peut arriver à trouver 400 fois des
horreurs à dire sur mon cou tout y passe
alors après à tous les fantaisistes qui
sont la iraqi dit mélenchon il veut
trouver la clé avec 100 milliards au tac
dit pas non 150 très bien bas pour cent
cinquante on en était hier à 160 le mal
qu'ils se sont donnés pour faire peur
pendant trois semaines et puis bon il ya
toutes sortes de gens pas mal à 1
mondiale à la jolla les chars
soviétiques de chavez vont arriver
catastrophe bon
mais ces défis qui arrive on va les
relever avec une force qu'on n'avait pas
et la machine à faire tenir les gens en
place elle est bien secoué ce soir parce
que de toute façon on l'a battue qu'il
n'a pas la même
et ce n'est pas rien c'est pas rien avec
le trois bouts de laine les quatre bouts
de ficelle on a fini par y arriver juste
à entêtement par ténacité par
opiniâtreté et parce qu'on a été tout en
tout cas pour tant que quand une sorte
d'arène cas mais voilà
à laisser tomber
alors au la batterie il n'a pas de
majorité et comme il a aucun brin si
voilà on entend encore une fois jean luc
mélenchon
peut-être qu'il sera pas premier
ministre mais quand même carrière de one
man show peut-être à entreprendre pour
la fin la fin de carrière politique
dernier grand tribun de la vie politique
jean-luc mélenchon il appartient cette
catégorie d'hommes politiques qui
considèrent que la rhétorique et la
capacité à un moment donné à emporter
par le verbe une foule constitue
l'élément tout à fait essentiel dans le
combat politique ils se jettent à dire
il se rattache à une tradition qui
remonte à la 3ème 4ème république même
au début de la vème république ça c'est
une évidence et ce qui ce qui fait son
succès aussi c'est ce qui fait son
succès parce que finalement il a il
marque un peu j'allais dire peut-être
qui peut apparaître aujourd'hui passé
sur le plan des codes de la
communication politique mais qui est
redoutablement efficace qui vous
rappelle qu'en effet la pratique ce
n'est pas que de la communication
christian gérondeau devrait être capable
de maîtriser le verbe christian jacob
est en train de prendre la parole elle
allait coûter on va l'écouter
je rappelle évidemment que c'est un
autre résultat qu on va commenter juste
après la déclaration de christian jacob
donc les républicains qui font plus de
deux fois moins
en 2017
la dernière projection estime d'ailleurs
le score des députés le nombre de
députés elle est rude et entre 55 et 80
députés on va écouter tout de suite
christian jacob position constructive
une vraie opposition à emmanuel macron
qui aura tout détruit son quinquennat
aura été un échec total
et c'est ce qui amène ce résultat
aujourd'hui
à votre disposition si vous voulez poser
des questions aussi la déclaration vous
suffit
oui pardon
si vous pouvez vous approcher sans
problème avoué au micro c'est bon c'est
bon ça julien dénis donc france
télévisions est ce que vous diriez comme
d'autres responsables politiques ce soir
que la france est ingouvernable
écoutez en tout cas nous avons une
assemblée comme nous ne l'avons jamais
eu et encore une fois cette la conduite
du quinquennat par emmanuel macron le
fait qu'il a instrumentalisé les
extrêmes on l'a vu à l'élection
présidentielle il a continué avec les
élections législatives et s'amène ce
résultat est encore une fois la balle
est dans son et dans son camp
aujourd'hui mais pour nous il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté
nous sommes dans une opposition
déterminée à emmanuel macron c'est la
position majoritaire au sein du parti
que c'est la position du parti jean
françois copé ou l impact du
gouvernement de jean françois copé parle
à titre personnel
le rassemblement national premier parti
d'opposition
temps des produits micro
bonjour monsieur jacob bonsoir le
rassemblement national premier parti
d'opposition à l'assemblée est ce que ça
vous inquiète oui bien entendu que c'est
inquiétant d'avoir à la fois l'extrême
droite et l'extrême gauche parce que il
ya les deux extrêmes et c'est ça le le
résultat de la politique conduite par
emmanuel macron pendant cinq ans
vous créé la présidence des républicains
à l'automne est ce que vous considérez
que vous laisserez le parti dans un bon
état si je puis hier à écouter compte
tenu de résultats de la présidentielle
je trouve que c'est un très bon résultat
auquel nous sommes arrivés aujourd'hui
bien entendu qu'on espère on espère on
espère toujours davantage mais vous
l'avez bien vu dans toutes les les
fourchettes qui ont été annoncées nous
sommes dans la fourchette haute et je
pense qu'on l'a dépassera mais
ce qu'il ya d'autres questions
c'est bon
voilà vous venez d'entendre donc
christian jacob le patron des
républicains qui est a déclaré donc son
party les républicains continueraient
d'être une fervente opposition emmanuel
macron ils désavouent donc le maire de
meaux jean françois copé qui est un
petit peu plus tôt dans la soirée a
appelé à un pacte de gouvernement avec
macron arnaud benedetti est ce qu'on
assiste ce soir à l'explosion de la
leyre on savait qu'il y avait plusieurs
dino lr finalement cette situation ne va
pas vraisemblement disons permettre le
renforcement de leur unité ça c'est
clair
moins qu'on puisse dire mais bon c'est
vrai que les gens qui lance énervé
vraiment certain nombre de leaders qui
au sein de des républicains n'ont pas
intérêt à ce qu'il y ait un accord de
gouvernement tout simplement parce
qu'ils pensent déjà au coup d'après et
quand on sait en plus que la situation
que va devoir gérer le prochain
gouvernement at-il situation qui sur le
plan économique social va être
extrêmement compliqué donc il n'y a pas
d' intérêts immédiats en tout cas pour
les républicains vraisemblablement à la
rentrée dans un dans un accord de
gouvernement
d'autant plus que leurs électeurs n'ont
pas forcément voté pour qu'il rende dans
un accord de gouvernement d'euros que ça
va être compliqué mais on peut imaginer
parce que c'est souvent le cas qu'il y
ait une stratégie un moment donné de de
débauchage d'un certain nombre de
personnalités étant au centre droit que
d'ailleurs au centre gauche parce qu'il
ya quand même quelques divers gauche
aussi dont il faudra regarder aussi le
comportement dans l'est dans les
semaines et dans les jours qui viennent
on peut imaginer que c'est disons dans
ses foyers là que emmanuel macron on va
essayer de constituer les briques
élémentaires d'une majorité mais ça
paraît quand même à ce stade très
compliqué et les propos de jacob sont
intéressants parce que en plus jacques
courbet il faut il faut le signaler
jacques courbet et françois jean
françois copé sont et lieu du même
département la seine et marne qu'ils
étaient assez proches
ne serait ce que pour ses looks à
l'autre à prendre
philippe lottiaux qui était le candidat
et rennes qui a dépassé eric zemmour a
dans le var a été élu député ce qu'on
vient de voir d'ailleurs sur le bandeau
il avait dépassé 2 je crois d'un peu
plus de 800 voix brisée mois au premier
tour
olivier ferrand qui a déclaré sur tf1
que nous allons très vite construire une
majorité absolue à l'assemblée nationale
alors avec qui du coup
c'est un peu le mystère on va attendre
de voir combien atterrissent les uns et
les autres mais la déclaration de jacob
et peut-être la déclaration c'est pas la
plus spectaculaire mais c'est sans doute
la plus intéressante il passait juste
après jean luc mélenchon qui était
tonitruant mais là ce que dit jacobs
rend les choses très classe que
finalement si vous voulez gouverner
aujourd'hui trouver des majorités avec
230 240 députés ensemble probablement
avec quelques divers gauche quelques
divers droite vous arrivez à 205 forcé
de la cuisine du calcul mais bête et
méchant mais on arrive à 250 si vous
avez 60 je sais pas si c'est à peu près
l'étiage prévu députés l air il faut que
les trois quarts d'entre eux ou un peu
plus
90% 85% soit de votre côté au moins pour
voter des grands textes économiques sur
lesquelles il peut y avoir de la
convergence entre eux mais là il dit
quelque chose qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas neutre jacob il aurait pu rester sur
son quant à soi considéré qu' il allait
prendre un peu de recul consulter je ne
sais pas ce qu'il nous dit la rend les
choses vraiment compliqué sur la
capacité de ce pays à être gouvernable
gouverner est en complète contradiction
avec ce que dit olivier ferrand parce
que chercher une majorité mais comment
et combien même dans les semaines qui
viennent pourraient avoir au passage
procéder à un remaniement
alors pour le coup c'est un remaniement
ce soir c'est olivier dehors on est
arrivé à une liste de 289 députés qui
disent on se range dans la majorité
c'est un corps vivant à l'assemblée
nationale avec combien de temps et
quelques fois qu'elle est sûr que pour
sur l'économie maïs sur le sociétal et
on est centré de la pratique le vème
république
c'est le quatrième est encore une fois
une majorité est véritablement exposés à
des risques de motion de censure
sur pratiquement tous les textes donc ça
va être extrêmement compliqué et s'ils
veulent en effet constituer une majorité
comme le prétend monsieur verra avec les
nerfs va se poser la question savoir
mais qui est le chef de cette majorité
parce que si les élèves veulent
éventuellement un certain nombre de l
air veulent éventuellement monter
aujourd'hui dans la barre cascio
majoritaire qui essaye de construire le
président a république ils peuvent être
je dire en situation de faiseurs de roi
en la matière et encore une fois la la
le j'allais dire même là le poste et la
légitimité même d'elisabeth board en
tant que leader de la majorité se posent
ce soir dès le 2 le résultat de ces de
ces élections très intéressant cette
remarque sur la page youtube des
filières où une assemblée paralysé vaut
mieux qu une majorité ensemble juge pas
du fond de sky de saisie
c'est très excitant
c'était peut-être véronique a déjà pas
mal d'infos là dessus sur les sur le
réseau mais dans les ans dans les
enquêtes emmanuel rappelé effectivement
le sondage que nous avions réalisé c'est
vraiment ce que ce que pensaient les
gens alors il ne mettait pas de signes
supérieur mais dans les deux cas il ne
voulait pas neil une majorité absolue
ensemble l'opinion des français étant on
en a soupé pendant cinq ans emmanuel
macron a fait ce qu'il voulait il a
méprisé l'assemblée il a méprisé
pense-t-il les les représentants là où
il va être obligé de gouverner en
échangeant en trouvant des compromis
sauf que ce qui se dessine ne le permet
pas c'eût été possible avec 270 députés
ensemble et en essayant de compter sur
une partie des républicains mais si on
est sur 230 ou 240 députés ensemble je
ne vois pas bien ce qui peut ressortir
certain c'est que je serai
je sais seulement que je regardais les
corpus de militants et l'eire qui n'est
pas la même chose que les sympathisants
mais des militants ait l'air eux disent
non mais il n'y a pas d'accord à avoir
d'abord parce qu'on ne voulait pas une
majorité absolue et on ne veut pas à qui
est d'accord et mêmes ils sont en train
de dire s'il y en a se dire qu on
disparaît définitivement bloquée dans
les pas question et les sympathisants
l'e10 c'est pas tant qu'il ne faut pas
d'accord mais il faut en discuter au cas
par cas en fonction
sujet des dossiers etc en imaginant que
un vrai débat sera possible et quand je
regarde sur l'ensemble des mines des
sympathisants 12 est sorti tous les tous
les militants ne sont pas bien normaux
les mines ils ne pensent pas comme tous
les français
là et des sympathisants globalement 10 à
ce qui va être intéressant c'est qu'on
rentre dans un régime parlementaire et
on sort des régimes précédents
ajustements parce que je l'y ai roulé
pendant le nom mais dans cet entre deux
tours il ya deux choses qui ont été
dites par les représentants de
l'autorité publique lui même cette
manière de renvoyer dos à dos la nuque
et le rassemblement national qui
maintenant l'angle d'attaqué principal
contre lui des représentants la nuque il
ya un autre point d'arguments qui a été
avancé qui était de défrayer les
français en disant attention si j'ai pas
de majorité ça n'ira pas parce que ce
sera un gouverneur et c'est là où on se
rend compte d'un peu de la faiblesse de
ses de cet argument parce qu'en fait il
ya beaucoup de français qui pense que de
toute façon ça ne va pas
et voilà sarkozy a été battue parce que
ça n'avait pas au nom n'a pas pu se
représenter parce que ça n'allait pas
emmanuel macron est le produit de ça ne
va pas et on n'est pas satisfait notre
vie démocratique donc avancé que ça
risquerait de mettre à mal un
fonctionnement démocratique de réponses
déjà qu'il est dysfonctionnelle ne
pouvait pas être un argument alors
justement cette question et de travail
intéressant de voir votre éclairage
sur le papier j'entends est dans la
logique de la vème république c'est un
gouvernable sauf qu'on a un problème une
crise de représentativité
depuis des années qui explique ces
situations de zapping depuis le début
depuis quinquennat depuis la réélection
de jacques chirac et même vous dire
depuis 2002 depuis la direction de
jean-marie le pen en 2002 finalement
cette forme qui paraît à gouvernable
mais elle est également la
représentation d'un pays qui est archi
paix lisée qui est fragmenté est ce que
quelqu'un comme emmanuel macron
finalement assez plastique
ac
qui joue le en même temps finalement ne
serait pas à même de pouvoir gouverner
avec finalement un pays qui a exprimé
tout ses sources et principal
sensibilité
la vraie réalité politique de la france
c'est le scrutin des dix latif ce soir
et non pas le scrutin présidentiel c'est
à dire que vous avez un état de
représentation de ce que constitue
vraiment le rapport de force aujourd'hui
du pays profond ça c'est je crois la
première leçon deuxième leçon c'est que
ce qui est inédit dans la situation à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés c'est
que c'est peut-être la première fois que
les institutions de la vème république
ne vont pas pouvoir jouer finalement le
rôle d'amortisseur et de stabilisation
du système politique parce que jusqu'à
présent quand on regarde vu les crises
sociale que nous avons traversée depuis
des décennies des décennies tous les
gouvernants peuvent dire merci à la
constitution de la vème république qui a
permis d'une certaine manière un certain
nombre de gouvernements de tenir le choc
face à des épreuves sociale et politique
comme on l'a connu d'ailleurs dans ce
dernier quinquennat là en l'occurrence
quand même en rond dans une zone
d'incertitude totale c'est à dire que
encore une fois malgré tout le talent
des manuels macron le problème c'est que
il est lui même aujourd'hui
l'instigateur involontaire de la
situation politique dans laquelle on se
retrouve c'est à dire dans une sauce de
situation on est en train quand même de
tangente et le blocage institutionnel
d'eau que ça va être extrêmement
compliqué la réaction quand même de
christian jacob et de ce point de vue là
je rejoins ce que vous avez dit est
assez importante parce que elle montre
qu'il ya quand même une partie de la
droite qui considère que ça fait déjà
depuis 2010 est qu'elle s'est fait voler
la victoire qu'elle devait qu'elle
devait et qu'elle n'a aucune raison en
tout cas s'il ya un certain nombre de
gens qui au sein des républicains
considèrent qu'ils n'ont aucune raison
de faire la courte échelle à emmanuel
macron donc très franchement je je je
considère que ça va être très compliqué
par contre en effet le point positif par
rapport à l'état de tension du pays par
rapport à l'état de tension du pays
notamment par rapport aux élites par
rapport à la classe dirigeante c'est que
ce résultat il al'avantage heroes
parlementarisme le régime il re
parlementariste la vie politique il
rééquilibre il rééquilibre d'autres
termes ce soir j'ai pu taire c'est fini
clairement c'est à dire que emmanuel
macron ne va plus pouvoir disent on être
aussi verticale qu'il a été ne serait-ce
que même dans sa communication parce que
tout simplement ils effacent il est
confronté face au mur de la réalité
politique le mur de la realpolitik cd
opposition qui sont multiples et variées
mais qui sont toutes déterminées dans
leur opposition emmanuel macron à gauche
à l'extrême droite et même en partie au
shérif public la force de macron jusqu à
présent c était quoi c'est de bénéficier
quand même de l'abstention où on a vu
que les classes populaires de se
mobiliser pas beaucoup et de la division
de la division de la classe politique
sauf que là bas la division est tel que
lui-même ben il est aujourd'hui frappé
par la fragmentation à laquelle il a
contribué
de la fin notre ya encore un mot de
conclusion véronique qu'est-ce qu'on
suit sur les réseaux ce soir est ce que
jean luc mélenchon les réseaux sociaux
guerre mon mot de conclusion on avait
parlé dans l'entre-deux-tours de chambre
introuvable en référence à celle liée
deux siècles qui étaient introuvables
parce qu'elle était tellement monarchie
ce que le roi disait il ya plus de
chambre ça sert à rien là on est face à
une chambre introuvable parce que
probablement qui aura pas de chambres
pas de discussion possible de la nuque
mais ce rassemblement national parce
qu'une chambre c'est un endroit où l'on
débat où on trouve des compromis et ma
crainte c'est qu'il nie de nouveau une
chambre drogba mais pour des raisons
diamétralement d'imposer un petit
références historiques très intéressant
cette référence à l'achat aurait trouve
à part celui qui a inventé le véritable
en même temps il ya un jeune historien
jean baptiste gaga qui vient de faire un
ouvrage sur cette question c'est un
premier ministre qui n'était pas
d'ailleurs premier ministre de louis
xviii qui avait inventé la politique de
la bascule la politique de la bascule
c'était de gouverne et d'un coup avec la
gauche un coup avec la droite en fait il
était le précurseur de d'emmanuel macro
game et matériels pardon je me permettre
pas phrase vermont parce que je pense
qu'elle dit deux points essentiels
la la fragilité et vient du coeur des
institutions et non pas et non pas du
contexte et l'autre point qui à mettre
en regard avec ça c'est qu'en fait c'est
l'élection présidentielle que constituer
l'exception sélection présidentielle qui
a fini par être dysfonctionnel et ces
élections législatives elles sont dans
la continuité de ce quinquennat et donc
on est véritablement je penche un peu
plus près encore pas une nouveauté pour
moi de là crise de régime merci arnaud
bd détient en tout cas vous avez des
fans sur lefigaro.fr claude jusque 15
qui dit excellent benedetti et naves
roche j'adore les analyses de benedetti
comment sont morts les politiques cette
édition du cerf et c'est le dernier
livre d'arnaud benedetti qu'on
recommande bien entendu chaudement et
nous on va ré écouter tout de suite
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon qui
se sont exprimées tout à leur mercie
emmanuel merci galles merci véronique et
on continue de suivre le baromètre
kantar c'est dans le prochain numéro du
figaro magazine le prochain sondage
backbone consulting au doxa aux hawks a
pas de bonnes consulting c'est à partir
de jeudi à découvrir sur une fille en
point fr et dans les éditions papier du
figaro
au terme de cette longue séquence
électorale de mise en place des
institutions pour le quinquennat qui
vient le peuple s'est exprimé
surmontant les obstacles d'un mode de
scrutin particulièrement injuste et
inadapté aux valeurs de notre temps il a
décidé d'envoyer un très puissant groupe
parlementaire de députés rassemblement
national à l'assemblée
[Applaudissements]
qui devient ainsi un peu plus nationale
ce groupe sera de très loin le plus
nombreux de l'histoire de notre famille
politique
c'est une situation totalement inattendu
absolument inouïe la déroute du parti
présidentiel est totale et au team
majorité ne se présente
nous avons réussi
l'objectif politique que nous étions
donnés en moins danois de faire tomber
celui qui avec autant d'arrogance avait
tordu brad tout le pays pour être élu
sans contact pour quoi faire
voilà et on va suivre qu'il
était battu exact les derniers résultats
avec vos outils beauté d'hellemmes tout
à fait brunet vincent les chiffres qui
continue de s'affiner minute après
minute on suit ça de près avec les
équipes du figaro d'après les dernières
estimations de l'ifop la liste de la
majorité présidentielle
remporterait 210 à 240 sièges à
l'assemblée nationale puis la nuque
baisse avec 170 à 180 15 députés le
rassemblement national avec 80 à 95
sièges et enfin les républicains qui
remporte ce soir 55 à 65 sièges voilà
pour les plus gros party du côté des
personnalités on l'a dit plusieurs
revers chez les ténors de la république
en marche christophe castaner richard
ferrand sont battus ce soir amélie de
montchalin que l'on savait menacé dans
la sixième circonscription de l'essonne
serait elle aussi battue est la ministre
de la transition écologique
recueillerait
46,3 pour cent des voix contre 53 7 %
pour le candidat du ps jérôme guedj
plusieurs ministres conforter ce soir
elisabeth banc dans le calvados tout
d'abord marc fesneau dans le loir et
cher franck riester également en
seine-et-marne large victoire aussi pour
gérald darmanin dans son fief de
tourcoing le ministre de l'intérieur qui
obtient 63 virgules 60% des voix dans la
10e circonscription du nord chez les
républicains eric ciotti annonce sa
victoire sur twitter pas de chiffres
officiels en ce sens qu'ils concernent
pour l'instant ça passe en tout cas pour
le secrétaire général des républicains
aurélien pradié qui l'emportent haut la
main dans le lot avec 64 2 63% des voix
face à son adversaire de la nuit baisse
elsa bougeard la nuque est ce justement
qui enregistre la victoire d'olivier
fort le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste l'emportent haut la main lui
aussi avec 64 65% des voix dans la 11e
circonscription de seine-et-marne
victoire également pour delphine batho
dans les deux sèvres et puis pour
terminer du côté du rassemblement
national je vous rappelle le score de
marine le pen 61 03 % des suffrages dans
la 11e circonscription du pas de calais
le porte parole du rassemblement
national sébastien chenu l'emportent lui
aussi avec près de 57 bien 57 % des voix
1 philippe ballard l'ancien journaliste
et lui aussi élu tout comme edwige diaz
qui devient la première député du
rassemblement national en gironde depuis
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup timothée
on vous retrouve très bientôt pour un
prochain point et on accueille les
plumes du figaro pour ce dernier plateau
judith waintraub un grand reporter au
figaro magazine bonsoir judith auteur
d'un article d'ailleurs très remarquée
et très remarquable à sur l'assassinât
du médecin militaire marseillais alvand
gervaise assassinat ou médiatiques et
politiques autour de cet assassinat en
même temps en partie brisée grâce à
votre art non aujourd'hui gérard bonsoir
et brownie choeur international au
figaro et jacques olivier martin
rédacteur en chef du figaro économie et
directeur éditorial du big band c'est la
semaine prochaine d'ailleurs dans des
studios du figaro grand mérite revient
de là également ce soir avec nous
d'abord peut-être une première réaction
est une réaction à ces résultats encore
provisoires mais c'est tendance mais
c'est
sans majorité et sans majorité de
rechange c'est à dire que même si on a
dit on garde la part dont la nuque sous
forme d'édition puisque je rappelle
qu'elle est une addition de plusieurs
partis on n'arrive pas au fatidique de
189 députés on en voit même pas la
possibilité qu'ils pourraient approuver
la nomination d'un premier ministre quel
qu'il soit
mais ce que je remarque c'est
l'énorme échec je vais qualifier une
fois dans un article du figaro jacques
chirac virgule le fléau de la france que
je pense et donc il a fait parmi les
nombreuses bêtises qu'il a fait et des u
le
raccourcissement du mandat présidentiel
à cinq ans parce qu'il s'agira
évidemment et amicale socialiste pas moi
mais ce côté compte un radical
ces grands partis se sont tellement
désiré n'avance qui se sont effondrés
ces grands patrons qui ont fait 88 7%
pour le patri par thébaux lice à la
présidentielle et qui ont fait 1,5 pour
avis aux séries voilà ces deux partis
qui effectivement été court le mandat à
5 ans voilà ce qu'ils ont fait voilà et
donc ces législatives malheureusement
n'intéresse plus personne je me souviens
de la passion en france pour les
législatives de 67 les lessives valises
de 73 celle de 78 et il y avait des
participations très important
aujourd'hui
54 % d'abstention c'est quand même moins
énorme une abstention à ce scrutin qu'il
n'y en avait eu au deuxième tour des
élections de business at on avait
atteint plus de 57% à venir
jacques-olivier à un commentaire alors
moi un commentaire une forme à peu de
sidération comme tout le monde c'est à
dire on est une grande surprise
j'imaginais pas qu'ils se produiraient
ça et puis très vite alors c'est un peu
le dans le texte que j'ai eues mais je
me suis dit tout ça pour faire quelle
politique et là
je n'ai pas de réponse - au-delà de la
sidération je suis à mon avis comme pas
mal de français un peu perdus pour
savoir ce qui va pouvoir se passer
quelle ce qu'est ce sur quoi on va
travailler dans un pays où on aurait
peine et s'il n'y a pas que la france
qui mérite des réformes quand même donc
c'est ça finalement mongin sentiment
d'inquiétude après la sidération 24 ce
que vous partagez bah oui quand je vous
dit y'a pas de majorité et pas de
majorité de rechange ça veut dire que
les institutions
voire paralysé nombre au sens juridique
du terme mais au sens politique du terme
est-ce que macro on va essayer de nouer
une alliance de gouvernement il ne peut
se tourner que vers l'est républicain
les républicains sont à l'heure où nous
parlons en train de s'affronter sur la
question faut-il ou et un pacte de
gouvernement avec le président la
république test de jean françois copé ou
au contraire éviter tout accord test de
eric ciotti réélu ce soit il ce soir
quand même christian jacot mais qui
semble avoir tranché dans dix ans les
républicains restent dans l'opposition
une opposition déterminée à évincer le
mac était plutôt la ligne oui mais de
toute façon les premiers résultats qu'on
commence à avoir
circonscription par circonscription
donne les durs simuler les les hostiles
à tout accord avec emmanuel macron
plutôt mieux servis par ces législatives
plutôt plus souvent réélu que les autres
je prends assez l'exemple auvergne
rhône-alpes la région de laurent
wauquiez il vient tous les candidats
wauquiez east les républicains qui se
présentait on gagne et ce soir on
revient pradier par contre bien élu dans
le dans l'autre ce serait plutôt
oui dans le fond dans le fond je parle
oui plutôt c est un peu tôt pour sonder
les quarts exaspère on aura cet exercice
à faire forcément on va regarder la
dernière projection ont été actualisés
avec l'infographie de kevin hébuterne si
on peut l'affiché donc on est toujours
sûr sur le même rapport de rapport de
force n ya pas vraiment de surprise mais
voilà donc là la coalition de la
majorité
rassemble entre 230 et 240 sièges donc
ça se resserre et la nuque baisse entre
165 et
175e et rennes perd aussi un petit peu
de sièges ils étaient 80 à 85 alors que
sur la première projection à 20 heures
on a on annonce est presque peut-être
100 sièges sans temps de jeu et puis les
républicains est associé à lui dit
qu'ils sont entre 62 et 68 moi je ne
suis pas inquiet pour évaluer le mac où
il va continuer à faire ce qu'il a fait
quand il est arrivé au pouvoir il a été
débauché un rpr et pas que ça s'appelle
plus à perth a fait
mais comme il change tous les deux ans
ça c'est drôle parce que dans les autres
démocraties des parties ne change pas de
nom tous les deux ans le parti
conservateur britannique qui s'appelle
toujours conservateur par les
travaillistes voilà aux états unis
partie des publications en france pas
pourquoi ils changent de phase et une
petite idée mais on va pas en parler
aujourd'hui pourquoi ils changent et
changent et changent et changent de
france voilà
je suis pas inquiet pour mes gars parce
qu'il va continuer à faire ce qui fait
qu'il a fait depuis le départ c'est à
dire qu'il prend dlr monsieur bruno le
maire est membre du gouvernement il
n'était pas l air monsieur monsieur
philippe est dans la majorité ils
n'étaient pas élèves philippe monsieur
rice terre il n'était pas l air voilà il
va continuer
alors on peut gouverner en france comme
gorka l'a montré avec une majorité
relative puisque voilà et
le couvert 261 sur une motion de censure
mais là le président pour envoyer les
députés face à leurs électeurs je suis
pas sûr qu'ils aient envie donc on peut
gouverner en france avec une majorité
relative et puis à voir des shows des
lois importantes toutes les lois qui
exige une majorité absolue avoir des
apports de des différents des différents
partis donc c'est vrai que c'est pas un
grand succès pour emmanuel macron mais
le premier tour des présidentielles
n'était pas non plus un immense succès
pour m c'était pas mal
en deuxième tour plus eu 2e tous plus
parce qu'effectivement à nouveau marine
le pen a été mauvaise en débat alors que
l'été se soient excellentes elle est
excellente elle sait pas que les débats
s'est pas fait pour elle les les
discours c'est vieux mais mais mais là
non non non je ne suis pas que je ne
suis pas inquiet pour emmanuel macron je
pense qu'ils pourront gouverner je
voudrais forme et on vous donne ma part
dans un instant jacques olive où vous
avez partagé pas la sérénité de renault
non parce que il suffit pas de débaucher
quelques personnes il faut obtenir une
une majorité pour gouverner on a
clairement compris en tout cas ce soir
c'est qu' aucun parti qui va vouloir en
tout cas sera lié d'une façon ou d'une
autre avec les le mouvement du président
donc à mon avis ça va être ça va être
extrêmement difficile
je redoute aussi on peut parler de
majorité relative mais je pense qu'ils
vont se faire fort dans l'opposition de
montrer de à emmanuel macron qui ne
voudront pas envie de le suivre donc je
pense qu'on peut se retrouver même s'il
avance seul sur un texte où il a une
majorité relative je pense qu'il peut se
retrouver que les oppositions qui
peuvent aller au delà de la majorité
relative est donc le mettre en minorité
donc ça je trouve que ça ça promet
d'être d'être complexe en tout cas moi
j'ai aucune cfa aucune certitude je vois
pas bien ce qui peut ce qui peut se
dessiner alors je sais pas peut-être que
je dit qui est spécialiste a peu de ces
domaines là on peut imaginer quelque
chose à ce qu'on peut avoir une surprise
ce qu au delà notre constat est ce qui
peut fabriquer quelque chose qu'on peut
ne pas imaginer balle à la réponse est
dans la question
la surprise serait qu'il arrive à
constituer un accord relativement
pérenne avec une partie des députés y en
a pas 36 solutions il est hors de
question pour la france a soumises et
pour le rassemblement national de nouer
un quelconque accord que ce soit avec
emmanuel macron c'est la grande
différence avec la période rocard où ils
constituaient effectivement ce qu'il
appelait les majorités d'idées en
prenant chez les centristes à gauche à
peu à droite au gré du vent on va au gré
des circonstances au gré la nature du
projet là c'est pas du tout pareil vous
avez deux alors le au fur à mesure de la
soirée on saura quel parti la france a
soumises du rassemblement national et le
deuxième partie de l'assemblée derrière
le parti des bagnoles macron pour
l'instant on ne sait pas ce qui laisse
ouverte des tas de questions comme la
présidence de la commission des finances
je vous épargne à la technique pas mais
qu'ils parlent tous d'ailleurs ce n'est
pas automatiquement dévolu aux premiers
goals impose ici le règlement de
l'assemblée stipule à un groupe
d'opposition un groupe qui se déclare
dans l'opposition donc il n'est pas
obligé d'être le premier mais cela dit
ah ça c'est le règlement par tradition
le groupe
majoritaire c'est à dire en l'occurrence
le groupe macro nice devrait ne pas
participer au scrutin
et si elle est fille est plus fort en
voie avec ses alliés de gauche pour
s'opposer à un choix qu'il ne paierait
pas et bien emmanuel macron ne pourra
pas lui imposer
je crois qu'ils ne désapprouverait est
importante et si je
oui non qui reste dans
l'est républicain et on voit à part ce
que je disais tout à l'heure que c'est
plutôt les durs et les adversaires d'un
compromis avec emmanuel macron qui ont
été mieux élu que les autres vous citiez
la déclaration de christian jacob le
vent ne tourne pas dans cette direction
là ni moi je suis incapable et sa fille
le même de prévoir ce que les
républicains vont faire dans l'est dans
les heures qui a décidé récemment
mène un groupe venant avec lui via
fransat magique et très marginalisés au
sein des républicains c'est pas lui qui
le fera
alors si je peux dire quelque chose elle
pouvait continuer ma vie c'est de vivre
la baie
si je peux dire quelque chose c'est que
si je me souviens bien mais sous le
contrôle de jean était de vous bien sûr
constitutionnel un gouvernement formé
sous la vème république n'a pas besoin
de demander de vote de confiance à
l'assemblée nationale ça passe il peut
s'en passer c'est très important c'est
très avantageux faut le rappeler il n'a
pas besoin de vote de confiance dont il
peut y avoir un gouvernement et gouverne
et après ils voient loi après loi loi de
finances après loi de finances etc
comment il peut sur les projets de loi
ou les propositions de loi à voir
des majorités
donc donc voilà donc c'est quand même
quelque chose de très important donc
voilà demain il peut y avoir un
gouvernement bande qui commence à le
gouverner sans doute avec divers mais
sur un remaniement puisque des ministres
juste ça c'est sûr il avait d'abord on
peut encore rester premier ministre
jusqu'en
difficile je ne sais pas je pense que
c'est compliqué il a voulu innover 7
sept premier ministre il ya quand même
très peu de temps mon avis il va tout
faire pour essayer de la maintenir après
ça dépend son projet qui veut construire
une fois de plus le problème c'est qu'on
ne sait pas on ne voit pas donc c'est
assez difficile je voulais rebondir sur
ce que disait rené girard effectivement
on peut gouverner je pense qu'il ya si
on est pragmatique il ya certains
projets politiques ou entre
le groupe de déminage macron et les
républicains où il ya des sujets assez
commun où ils pourraient s'entendre
aucun parent carte si ça suffit pour
arriver à 200 ça tombait pas cela mais
deux fois le nucléaire le
peut-être la réforme des retraites
peut-être que qui est quand même une
réforme fondamentale je suis gêné de
dire que j'ai pas beaucoup d'autres
choses à dire parce que on sort quand
même d'une campagne où le président de
la république ça a c'est assez peu
exposé sur ces sur ses projets donc
je pense qu'il paye de ne pas avoir
refusé d'aller sur le terrain de faire
campagne ou en tout cas son parti
pendant pendant six semaines enfin il a
fait un pari politique absolument fou
qu'il est en train de payer qui est ce
pari de se dire que je peux attendre les
commentateurs l'ont dit et répété
pendant six semaines il a cru qu'on
pouvait gagner une élection sans se s'en
aller sans se bat pour la chanson
mouiller la chemise et ben non ça marche
pas comme ça et finalement je trouve que
c'est pas si mal que ça se passe comme
ça parce que ça veut dire que les choses
sont sont plus complexe que ça les
français veulent
être gouvernés par des gens qui ceux qui
font le travail qui se battent pour des
projets qui se battent pour daisy alors
débat pour vous 3 d'ailleurs quand on
regarde la performance annoncée du
rassemblement national à quoi vous
attribuez ça est-ce que vous attribuez
ça au fait qu' il y avait un refus de
macron au fait que le pouvoir d'achat
sont encore le thème dominant de la
campagne ou bien que des thèmes sur
lesquels traditionnellement le
rassemblement national faisait campagne
qui sont les thèmes régalien qui sont
l'immigration n'ont pas été abordés
pendant la campagne et je crois que
c'est un peu un mélange de tout ça mais
c'est surtout la constance de marine le
pen alors ça peut paraître bizarre de la
part de quelqu'un qui a changé d'avis il
pas qu'un peu et pas sur des détails
comme rester ou sortir de l'union
européenne mais force est de constater
que depuis qu'elle prépare c'est cette
présidentielle là elle a gardé une
position que ce soit sur le fond je ne
citais l'europe ou sur les alliances
refus total d'alliance avec eric zemmour
qu'elle a gardée or la période a quand
même été marquée par des de l'ambiguïté
et du faux du côté des manuels macron du
côté de la gauche j'en parle même pas
olivier faur brillamment réélu ce soit
pour avoir foulé aux pieds tout ce
toutes les valeurs étaient censés adhéré
en tant que socialiste n'en parlons pas
mais l'absence de constance par exemple
on l'a vu sur ce plateau même le soir du
premier tour rappelez vous on se
demandait quelle allait être la consigne
d' emmanuel macron en cas de duel et
rennes et du ps
on a appris on était là que lors de la
réunion d'état major au tour d' emmanuel
macron le président avait dit aucune
voix pour les extrêmes chose qu'a répété
elisabeth bande dans sa première
intervention et alors là ça a été une
pagaille absolue les gens venus de la
gauche qui appartiennent à la main
majorité sortante dix ans mais il n'est
pas question de mettre sur le même plan
le rn et elle est fille
elisabeth borne a été obligé de se
dédire élevé les a fini par quoi ça a
fini par on verra au cas par cas quel
extrême gauche et fréquenta lequel nubes
est fréquentable qu'elle ne l'est pas ça
ça se paye dans les yeux elisabeth
demande qu'on a toujours pas entendu ce
soir je rappelle qu'elle a été élu dans
sa circonscription rock ric rac à 52,53
c'est pas c'est pas un plébiscite
je crois pour répondre à votre question
là sur eux marine le pen ya quelque
chose qui était assez frappant c'est que
dans
le débat contre
emmanuel macron l'a2 telle qu'elle n'a
pas du tout évoqué un jour été à sa
place j'aurais martelé la chose ce sont
les thèmes de l'immigration et thème de
la sécurité est là dans le discours là
j'ai entendu ces deux thèmes qu'elle a
repris en premier si vous n'avez
immigration insécurité
précarisation de sa fan à fait
différente l homme c'est sûr qu'entre
temps entre la présidentielle et
ses initiatives
on a eu l'exemple un peu consternant du
stade de france à desrosiers mais y voit
là où l ordre france on veut accueillir
les jeux olympiques
voilà voilà
sasson touristes français qui font faire
les poches et le préfet n'est pas viré
le ministre est content mans un peu à la
nage voilà et alors là là effectivement
effectivement les gens se sont dit il ya
quelque chose qui ne va pas en france et
c'est à mon avis ce phénomène du stade
de france a beaucoup aidés le vote pour
marine le pen
question subsidiaire ono est ce que
là dans ces élections là tout à l'heure
les politologues qui étaient autour de
cette table ont dit finalement
l'élection un peu exceptionnel
anecdotique à normale entre guillemets
c'est l'élection présidentielle
al'inverse est ce que cette élection
législative française par ces résultats
à la fois une forte poussée donc de du
rnd de la nul plein de la gauche quand
même avec quand même des insoumis qui
vont passer de quinze députés à 80
peut-être 90 députés c'est pas le sens
entre guillemets d'une histoire que l'on
est en train de connaître en occident
qui est la poussée et qu'ils aient
commencé en grèce il y à il ya 20 ans il
ya 15 ans la poussée des mouvements
populistes oui alors là qu'elle soit il
faut s'entendre sur le mot de populiste
est-ce que moi aussi j'étais pop il dit
je dirais mobilisent c'est quoi c'est
j'ai pas les mêmes idées que vous sauf
que joue bas aux élections vous me
traiter de populiste voilà enfin quand
il ya un refus des élites il ya une
dénonciation il ya un recours à un
recours à l'état il ya une dénonciation
d'une d'une politique qui ne se veut pas
représentative oui bah dans l'histoire
ait eu beaucoup de mouvement populaire
populiste les jacobins et sans doute des
populistes c'est bien commander voilà
en tout cas effectivement il ya une une
contestation en europe assez fort de ces
familles politiques on voyait s'entendre
par exemple pour faire
un traité de lisbonne par exemple j'ai
eu un truc et c'est intéressant en effet
sous sarkozy c'est que y'a deux pays et
c'est important et fondateur de l'union
européenne qui avaient rejeté
à une très forte majorité de plus de 5
5%
la nouvelle constitution européenne la
france et les pays bas voila voila moi
j'étais très triste que vous avez été
fait par des français cette position
masse était comme ça voilà c'est pas
grave on a derrière on est allé à
lisbonne en fait on a pris la position
de même le même texte et sarkozy et ben
voilà on va pas le faire passer par là à
le parlement et ce tant pis mais votre
voix qui comptent pas par lbo c'est un
événement fondamental dans la confiance
et dans le diwan
dévoile à ses dires votre vote au
référendum et là il n'y avait pas de
l'abstention à votre peau de vote et ne
compte pas et bon alors évidemment après
jacques olivier
l'agenda économique va être très
compliqué entre les réclamations des uns
et des autres et l'état des finances
absolument absolument on ne sait pas où
on va là aussi les les défis sont sont
absolument considérable on doit faire un
projet de finance rectificatif la dans
l'est dans les jours qui viennent et
puis après on doit préparer le prochain
budget qui sera présenté pour l'année
2000 23 dans lequel généralement il ya
des textes très important était que
simple fondateur de grandes réformes
pour le pour le quinquennat est
généralement le premier budget est le
plus important alors la france est
exactement c'est pas ce qui va se passer
il y aura le projet de loi enfin le
projet de loi en tout cas le projet dead
au pouvoir d'achat alors qu'il a ça
risque d'être débattue mais globalement
suivi puisque faut quand même si on doit
aussi regarder ce qui s'est passé dans
dans les partis qui ont une forte
poussée ce soir c'est quand même de
nippes et le rassemblement national j'ai
envie de dire s'est départi de guichet
c'est à dire que l'état peut tout l'état
peut tout distribuer donc que le guichet
viennent des macros nist qui veulent
faire comme ils l'ont annoncé des
mesures de soutien au pouvoir d'achat
ici opposeront peut-être ils voudront
peut-être jusqu'à ce qu'on soit là mais
ils seront ils seront pas content je
fais juste une parenthèse mais on l'a
aussi largement commentée ce phénomène
là qui était déjà assez français peut de
compter sur l'état
pour pour un soutien financier permanent
finalement ça a était exaspéré avec le
quoi qu'il en coûte et puis la
conjonction d'une politique européenne
notamment aux politiques européennes et
et la politique de la banque centrale
européenne qui a permis de distribuer de
l'argent et beaucoup d'argent la
combinaison des deux fait qu'aujourd'hui
on pense que l'état va pouvoir lutter
contre le pétrole cher lutter contre
l'inflation lu dans ce n'est pas
possible ou c'est un âge où on va
retomber on est déjà en train de
retomber avec des taux d'intérêt qui
pourrait monter et là on va se retrouver
dans une situation où un l'europe n'a
bce va changer de politique c'est déjà
un peu le cas
2 les taux d'intérêt vont monter et donc
dans quelques années 1 point de taux sur
dix ans et 42 milliards d'euros de plus
de taux d'intérêts à payer on n'est pas
dans des petits montants là on est déjà
à plus de 2.2 tôt alors ça met du temps
mais ça peut aller très très très très
vite bon donc on est dans une situation
où sur le défi économique on risque
d'avoir des jusqu'au boutistes de l'aide
publique
est peut-être que c'est là où on pourra
se retrouver on pourra imaginer que se
retrouve peut-être les maquereaux lien
avec les républicains c'est qu'il ya
quand même
du côté de maquereaux et plus encore des
républicains l'idée qu' il n'y a pas
d'avenir sans travail a pas de création
de richesse son travail donc réforme des
retraites d'autres réformes peut-être
sur l'assurance chômage et là il faut
aussi qu'on avance de ce côté là et moi
j'attends de voir le futur gouvernement
s'il aura le courage de faire autre
chose que de distribuer un pouvoir
d'achat qui est produit sur deux de
l'endettement il est 22h03 d'assaut et
caravaca nous as été passionnant daphné
caravaca viennent de rejoindre les
derniers résultats les élus les battues
et par excès de stanislas guérini
l'ancien patron des républicains et des
patients de la république en marche
pardonnez-moi est en très mauvaise
posture oui vincent alors pour le coup
on va démarrer ce point info avec
l'intervention de jeu luc mélenchon
qu'on a suivi plutôt sur figaro live qui
salué la déroute totale du parti
présidentiel parce que maintenant que
les chiffres s'affiner que les
déclarations affluent le scénario d'une
majorité relative devient réel et en
cause notamment le score de la nuit
baisse qui obtiendrait entre 165 et 175
sièges et qui représenterait le plus
grand groupe d'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale parmi les résultats des têtes
d'affiché de gauche très attendu ce soit
fabien roussel ancien candidat à
l'élection présidentielle qui a été élu
dans la 20e circonscription du nord avec
54% des voix mais aussi olivier faure le
premier secrétaire du ps qui a été
largement réélu avec 60 5% des voix en
seine et marne et enfin delphine batho
qui l a été élu avec 57 % de l'autre
côté de l'hémicycle et plus
particulièrement du côté des
républicains pour des morts on est bien
vivant c'est ce qu'a dit rachida dati et
pour cause le groupe qui représentait la
principale force d'opposition avec 112
élus à l'assemblée depuis 2017 a perdu
des sièges et en aurait d'après nos
derniers chiffres entre 62 et 68 parmi
les victoire et l'ère eric ciotti et
christelle dean torny ont tous les deux
été élus dans les alpes maritimes le
numéro trois des républicains
aurélien pradié aurait été réélu en
balayant la candidate de la nièce dans
la première circonscription du lot avec
64% des voix et enfin le dernier point à
retenir l'ancien ministre ump jean
françois copé à lui appelé à un pacte
entre les républicains et une coalition
de la majorité de la présidentielle
ensemble merci beaucoup daphné et alexis
brézet nous a rejoints alexis la une du
figaro à l'épreuve d'une france aux
gouvernants à l'épreuve d'une france 5
gouvernable je ne sais pas où est la
caméra de cicéron vous avoir fait
exactement pourquoi libre avec fort
saganne al parce que la france s'étant
gouvernable et que ça va être rude
épreuve alors quelques idées je vais
créer des postes et justement ça va elle
évacuer en fait l'a été au delà de nos
bacs est ce que tout ça est comme très
sérieuse c'est que la croix sur une
défaite cinglante et qui se retrouvent
sans majorité c'est à dire que le
président élu il ya quelques semaines
avec 58% des voix se retrouve
aujourd'hui absolument sans majorité
alors on disait avant oui mais il lui
manquera peut-être quelques voix il ment
pas quelques voix il manque plusieurs
dizaines de voix ça va donc être
extraordinairement difficile de faire
voter le moindre texte donc on peut
parler toutes les réformes heureux mais
la question est comment vont-ils demain
faire voter sa loi prenons quelques
exemples déjà la déclaration de
politique générale
il avait demande si elle découvre
conduit dans ce compromis serait pas
obligé d'en faire une si au final est
pas obligé de faire un vote
si elle qu'un vote elle n'aura pas de
majorité positives en sa faveur elle
peut attendre une motion de censure et
il est peu probable effectivement que ce
coup-ci lanuf d'un côté leur assemblée
nationale de l'autre la droite votent la
même motion de censure donc elle peut
passer entre les gouttes et résisté à